a September
12.
still summer
and it's still hot
I mean who's ready for fall I mean
who's over this kind of weather say wayo
gotta get some whales at home everybody
I heard all you guys at home
too damn hot
today's episode is sponsored by
hellofresh
we have actually a pretty crazy episode
planned for you guys
um
I don't know if you guys have heard
about this one chip challenge business
here
[Music]
this is a
I've seen a lot of people doing this
apparently they updated every year
and this is the 2022 one
and apparently this one's the worst one
they've made like this is
seems to be insanely hot
[Music]
yes thank you will
now I'm no stranger to doing spicy stuff
I've been on hot ones and I did all the
hottest burger in the world stuff
so
I'm I'm scared
but I think I can do it I mean I can
oh but a lot of these guys are going to
be doing it everybody but Dan
and Sam are
are gonna do it Ian or Dan what's your
rationale
uh well
it is my mic working yeah I can hear you
okay
um
well I was down to do it at first and
then I went to go order them and I saw
the reviews and it kind of uh
the reviews I mean every single review
for this thing is saying don't do this
this was the worst decision I've ever
made in my life and I'm not really even
exaggerating it's wall-to-wall people
saying that really but what's the rating
then on like Amazon five stars
five stars I would never do don't do
this five stars also somebody is going
to have to switch once uh Ian gets
knocked on his ass by this thing that's
the best excuse I think that we need a
babysitter that we're about to do like a
LSD trip we need one sober person here
yeah last this was our last spicy
challenge
is this this is a b who p is just a
puker I think you just really you just
like it all right that was hell I don't
know I it was worse coming back up but
that was a nightmare and it was a year
ago September is this is just Lena
babysitting yeah
and this was from we got a bottle of the
last dab extreme from hot ones right
yeah yeah oh and you went crazy with it
you ate like a whole what did you do
yeah I had another one after I was
already dying or something
but I made no but you took like a mess
I think I said I just had to take one
bite and I finished it all
yeah so
everyone's participating but Sam and is
Sam here she's she's working on
something downstairs I believe hey I got
I guess I'll I should wait to tell you
guys about Sam but Sam is actually
um gonna be working with Teddy fresh
more as the creative lead
she's so talented
as you guys have seen on the show with
her prop making and and her creative
abilities she helped the teddy fresh
guys with the peanuts photo shoot that
came out great and so we're actually
um super excited to be
Sam Temple I think the gifted stuff
including hurts thank you Sam more and
Teddy fresh as the creative lead so she
can be working on both teams at the
moment but but um yeah super exciting
stuff
you go girl
um
everybody watching on this or that stop
putting that [ __ ] on me dude everyone
watching here
come to YouTube [ __ ] Tick Tock and
Instagram come to YouTube thank you
um do we need to explain that for the
YouTube audience oh yeah we're live
streaming on tick tock
and Instagram
just curious if it like will help funnel
people in and let people know we're live
a little bit of an experiment
people seem to be loving it okay chat is
lovely okay we'll do it live yeah
inspired by Ninja he's like I'll be live
everywhere I was like well why don't we
do that hello
what the hell was that
those ninjas saying hello to the crew
hello Ethan Klein boys over there
say hello again
hello
does it sound anything like him
it's Nina that's him he got so mad at
himself this moment
yeah so
um
so that's what we're doing obviously
this is a more of an off the rails thing
but we said you know screw it we're
going to do it today
we're gonna get after it
so uh the game is going to be we're
going to have one person sit next to me
in the hot seat and the challenge is to
eat the chip
chew it down swallow it and then whoever
can go the longest
without drinking
or eating I guess
there should ain't never seen hard
I mean there's gonna be some cycle that
can just go forever right or because
maybe we should limit it at like five
minutes or something you don't think
anyone's gonna lie in fact I I feel the
opposite it's all going to be like 10
seconds really that bad
I will say I don't I didn't want to
scare you guys too much
but I did some research on this too
and I'll just say
it's [ __ ] hot
like there's a there's a chili pepper
channel that reviews spicy hot things
like that's his whole [ __ ] because he
eats raw
Peppers the spiciest peppers the
Carolina Reapers and all that crazy the
demon jizz whatever they call them these
days
Satan's foreskin whatever
and uh he he gave it an eight he thought
it was very very very hot give it an 8
out of ten okay
[Music]
I'm curious if you'll say it's hotter
what's hotter that or the um
whatever the hot pepper pepper x hot one
sauce or whatever yeah yeah but did you
guys see how hot he looked yeah but
um it'll be entertaining so you know and
I don't think nobody's died from it
nobody's been Gravely injured they
haven't even been sued yet oh yet
it's all changing today yeah today
everything changes
You Ain't Seen Nothing Yet turned your
tongue blue apparently too so okay
there's a warning on it it says do not
eat if you are sensitive to spicy food
obviously
allergic to Peppers
obviously nightshades are caps capsaicin
or are you pregnant or have medical
conditions no pregnancies you will have
an abortion
guaranteed abortion hey you know what
we've just found a good loophole that's
a good alternative I used all those in
uh Louisiana women in Texas one chip
challenge on Amazon for real no you
don't even need a doctor's slip
it's terrible what if you just and I and
I sorry if I'm being uncouth I'm just
trying to help the people who are
struggling what if you didn't put it in
your mouth oh boy here we go nah where's
that medical no [ __ ] you know I'm just
saying I'm just I'm just giving ideas it
would get the job done it's a desperate
time it's a desperate time and [ __ ] too
thank you
I didn't want to say it
it says keep Out Of Reach of children
that's the one thing I'm curious about
with this
because you can there's no age limit on
Amazon to buy it and like some dumbass
10 year old could
I mean I guess 10 is not that bad I've
seen kids doing it on tick tock
where they're like [ __ ] up uncles like
all right I'm gonna give you five bucks
if you eat this whole chip
and then the kid didn't go to school for
the rest of the semester
um it says wash your hands with soap do
not touch your eyes or sensitive areas
seek medical assistance should you
experience difficulty breathing fainting
or extended nausea Maybe
I I don't know if I can do this man Zach
oh my God I'm not gonna peer pressure
you I'm not gonna do it I I'm not going
to do that I'm not going to do it
I just remember Zach who once said
anything I will but I feel like heat is
a different thing in mind no I'm not
going to peer pressure you though if you
don't want to do it then I might take
out just an incy beansy bite just to put
my toes in the water and see
thanks buddy yeah we'll be there we'll
be there at the funeral don't worry
so
um
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna say anything
to Zach okay he's 100 titled
to make his choice I just wrote him on
our team chat Zach you're such a [ __ ]
in case you guys wanted to know what
he's talking about
this is the man oh thank you yeah we
have a team Discord for live notes and
stuff how many exclamation marks one two
three four five six seven eight this is
the man that once ate how much Horsey
Sauce is I mean come on packs and pool
full of mayonnaise but I feel like it's
different I don't know I'm gonna it just
is it just is I don't
I don't know I'm gonna I'm gonna dip my
toes in the water we'll see we'll see
we'll see
I just okay but my respect for a b is
going up more that's fine as Zach um
uh respectfully declines
and I will not peer pressure him so
anyway that's going on did I say thank
you to hellofresh I did I think yeah you
did thank you again though shout out
yeah I love them man they're keeping
this whole show flow pretty much um
shout out to our members by the way
there's a new BTS going up after the
show yes indeed yes sir any any cool
interesting things to report therapy uh
they're always cool and interesting
nothing specific comes to mind at this
moment but Cam and Cam and I do some
manly men labor yeah right it's like
conversation
OSHA violation OSHA violations shirtless
and sweating uh no the shirt stayed on
no come on
remember to find out that's a good point
sure listen sweating only cams behind
the cam only cam only dance
do a little preview I'm getting really
I'm button this little couple of notches
yeah so um that's that but I hope
everyone had a good weekend
I had a pretty fun weekend this throat
thing you guys remember I had like a
sore throat and then on Wednesday and
Friday we did Mega episodes so
my throat's been a little messed up
probably not a good time to eat the
world's spiciest chip I wonder if that's
gonna
burn my the back of my throat
but we'll see I'm I'm in it you know
because for me the most important thing
is
making sure that we have an entertaining
show
right and that that to me is why like I
know it's gonna be
I'm probably not going to love the
experience but like I'm willing to do
that to myself to create an entertaining
show and all you guys are too which is
so cool and amazing I mean thank you to
everybody why are you cut to me dude
who's eating the chip
what's up so thank you to everybody
who's eating the chip uh for love of the
show here
yeah unlike David I actually do the
stunt with you guys thank you
I'm participating I'm all right on that
excavator with you guys so solidarity
right
[Music]
um
so I guess we'll do it after the break
just give it we all like busted down
massive breakfast burritos I'm trying to
make sure that everyone's stomach is
fortified as much as possible we have
I'm gonna make everyone take a shot of
Pepto-Bismol before the chip goes down
if you want you don't have to I'm going
to I recommend it I think it'll help
because like the spicy mouth thing is
one thing but getting like stomach
cramps and pain is not a fun not a part
of the challenge that's interesting or
fun you know I yeah so I'm trying to
avoid that I didn't want to get too lewd
but part of the reason I'm not doing it
you had diarrhea my stomach is having
some issues already today and throwing
that in there sounds like a man had
diarrhea you guys you told me he said I
was having diarrhea all weekend human
fecal matter I was like really Dan write
up the first thing in the office
um
you know what's kind of weird I've been
seeing this and apparently this is a
thing that's going on now
it's heart is this isn't just Target
this is like a lot of these CVS
convenience stores yeah
um
they're locking [ __ ] all the Sundries
and bathroom stuff behind cabinets
I mean
what in the [ __ ] are we doing here now I
was freaked out when I saw
baby food is locked behind the cabinets
when I you know first had a kid because
it's like the most essential thing you
can imagine
but the fact that so many people are
stealing that
is both scary and [ __ ] up
because how many babies are how many
babies are starving you know what I mean
that we're stealing baby food off the
[ __ ] aisle
and then they're like no don't feed your
baby it's a this is Cap this is like the
this is the uh
capitalism right here really interesting
look at it but yeah so guys shampoo
apparently
behind glass hot commodity I mean what
is that five bucks I don't get it well
you gotta call a rep you know how
annoying it is when you have to call
rept by alcohol or something now you
want to get some head and shoulders
you're going to get some Dew to come
open it for you like what the [ __ ] and
he's gonna be like yo I'll take this up
for you it's like it's five dollar
shampoo dude
I seen in an article that a lot of
customers are complaining so they're
developing an app to allow you to unlock
it yourself
yeah seriously
yeah I don't know I think I think what
this says to me is that we need to get
some baby food and shampoo in the in the
hands of uh
of our poor and uh
lower classmen I don't think they need
to be worrying about stealing that [ __ ]
let's you know let's give them some baby
food
you know it's okay if it has a little
lead I don't expect it to be like the
best quality
baby food but like so just so they don't
have to steal it you know
right if there's a little asbestos it's
fine yeah they'll deal with that later
not the same quality as the wealthy
babies get but no no something I'm
saying at least they're not gonna starve
yeah so that was one we saw that was a
Reddit post here's another one
this is at a um
oh there's no photo of it yeah this was
just more people pointing out Emeryville
where's Emeryville
an Emeryville in Northern California
actually yeah yo Sam you took this photo
Sam's downstairs right now but yes no
she's right there oh I'm right here
she's everywhere I did take that picture
yeah I took uh yeah there was one of the
head and shoulders and then the
toothpaste across the aisle oh the
toothpaste is 1.99 yeah Colgate 199.
yeah so yeah it's super weird and
everyone was really confused but like if
this is how it's going to be at Target I
feel like I'm not going to shop there if
I have to wait for someone to like
unlock [ __ ] Jeff Bezos is laughing
[Laughter]
they're going to do that with all of the
health and beauty stuff
so that's like a lot
they're gonna have to hire more people I
feel like yeah damn where are you going
with my Pepto bro
oh really you you Dan is hitting the
Pepto he's not part of the challenge
ladies and gentlemen
Dan everybody hitting the Pepto early
he cannot wait
have you diarrated at the office today
Dan
a couple times he said that's pretty bad
hell yes
yep yep yep
so
I just I mean you guys have seen these
videos of people like they go into like
CVS and just grab a bunch of [ __ ] and
leave
I don't know what the details on that
but apparently in San Francisco Bay Area
they
aren't putting people in jail for like
petty theft so people just
they just but so they I guess there's
just like a big wave of crime I don't
know if this is what they're dealing
with but this is in La I remember I
don't think I don't know if that happens
in L.A the whole thing is just so odd
man these razors around the open though
I'm placing these do you know about the
no chase rule no chase yeah and like
some states if you steal something and
you leave the store the the employees
can't chase you and I think that that's
a smart rule I mean if I'm an employee
I'm not running for minimum wage right
it's a win but no chase yeah
it loses
so this is the world man we're coming to
I think
I think it's really really sad 199
toothpaste
is not anymore the way it used to be a
demand brushes teeth
you know have respect at least they care
about their hygiene you know
what are we gonna do about it all about
the respect
all right there you have it
uh our world is crumbling before our
eyes
I'm afraid of even playing this Tick
Tock because you're so much like like
like here's a chiropractor he says
he says so your neck hurts so your neck
hurts yeah but he literally he says the
n-word
I don't even think he he tried to say
does your neck hurt he just straight up
says right it sounds like that it's
weird I went down the rabbit hole on
this a little bit and he mentions in the
comments that it was a mistake it just
when he said it came out that way but
then I learned that another chiropractor
did the same thing it almost had the
same exact response in his comments as
well and they both go super viral right
yeah dude chiropractors are such
scumbags y'all I'm not surprised at all
that they're out there dropping n bombs
on Tick Tock by the way Sam I told
everyone at home about your um
I would say
promotion slash vertical uh step into
Teddy fresh
creative leading
so everybody knows about it so if if Sam
is sometimes not at her seat or
something she's probably hoping Teddy
fresh out but yeah I'll let everybody
know who's Sam
I know who Sam is you guys
Sam are you joining us for the chip
challenge
I think I'm too [ __ ] honestly okay
that's fine because Zaff also he's Zach
for Deadpool
was uh we just talked about how
important it is to do whatever it takes
for the show you make it entertaining
call me a [ __ ] no I didn't
um
I mean I'm right there with you though
so
I don't know but I don't I don't recall
Sam ever saying she'd do anything for
the show that's all well I mean I would
but not not everyone not everyone can
have a joker brain you know I'm a little
frightened by the type of pepper that I
saw on the package Joker's like this is
a little too spicy
that's not Joker brain
that is true that's not very Joker brain
of you oh what the [ __ ] now you're
instigating it too well well I'm just
saying you say your joke about you
you're the one that put yourself on this
pedestal yeah dude you're being a little
[ __ ] brain right now not so I'm just
saying the reason if it feels like we're
bowling you or like peer pressuring you
it's because we are right people are
calling us lack and lamb but I'll get on
an excavator I won't eat the chip though
no but but the reason is is because you
talk such a big game that's all I've and
I've proven myself how you literally
you're you oh go easy on young Zack he
he definitely has proved himself come on
dude he flopped around in a [ __ ]
kiddie pool full of mayonnaise extreme
he loved that yeah he's disgusting he
acts like he hates it but that's the
kind of [ __ ] he dreams about he smelled
like Mario every night but then I dream
of diving in a pool full of mayonnaise
yeah he smelled like Mayo for a week but
that's a joker move though you know that
that you may have loved it okay here's
and I'm gonna say this again I'm going
to dip my toes in the water and we'll
see what happens
I'm not saying no
yeah okay I mean obviously he's gonna
end up doing it okay I hope so that'd be
great
Lena's doing it by the way so that's
really exciting proud of her that's just
incredible and Olivia and Olivia right
Legends
women are stronger than men it's a
proven fact
well some men I just think yeah I mean
it said depends on the people yeah
exactly
with some men sounds kind of sexy no
just like some women are stronger than I
mean yeah just like some men are
stronger than some woman
all right well the good news is we do
have an excavator in back sack so I
anticipated this so I'm gonna put your
ass up there and swing you around
one-eyed Bernstein here we come
the one-eyed bird
um so I'm not gonna watch the
chiropractors because you know these
guys are monsters
um this was pretty interesting riding
off of the poor Queen's death I mean who
saw it coming you know what I mean oh uh
before you open it you may want to
instead watch the link right below is it
better angle
oh air oh shoot Arab world news covered
I saw this just before the show
yes so I I don't know if you guys heard
but the queen I know it's shocking
because she was just so young uh it's so
tragic but she died
I know it's hard to believe man
so I always say the good always Die
Young
it's just not fair
unimportant announcement Buckingham
Palace has announced the debt of her
majesty Queen Elizabeth II
all right come on we got we got a show
to do that was that was so last week
okay
[Music]
we get a close-up in this corner no
because the other one we get to see the
legend
yeah it cuts to it oh we get like
multiple angles yeah some young man's
actually in the audience just screaming
at the
it's calling Andrew
yeah if you listen closely what does he
say actually no that's not your ID right
right that's interesting
not sure what he was talking about his
name's not Chapel
oh he's he's a sick calling him a p word
right or some [ __ ] yeah you're sick and
disgusting sick and kind of based I mean
let's not parade this guy around he's
Epstein's homie I mean he's pretty much
all but confirmed to be
yeah he's part of a sex trafficking
operator did they say in England he's a
he's a nonce a bit of a notes mate
so like let's not have a March in the
parade and celebrate him I mean um guys
let's not forget who this what what the
[ __ ]
I mean guy you don't remember Jimmy
Savelle y'all just dealt with that and
said never again and here he's marching
in the parade
Jim will fix it watch when this guy dies
when parents Andrew dies there's gonna
be like 20 documentaries about how did
we see this coming
the man had an island
he was sacrificing the Young no no but
he could have seen it coming
here they are talking about if to get a
redhead or a blonde for the next Lolita
flight
Epstein says why not both
that's the game
what do you think they're talking about
oh Sports
Finance
uh how them Cowboys doing
hey you're a bit of a nance mate Game of
Thrones Maybe
well
in a sense
okay all right somebody said Michael
says about you Zach
uh Zach Attack has more than proven his
medal on this podcast he's ride or die
don't undersell the home I agree with
Michael thank you thank you Mike I think
he's earned weikel weikel he's earned
that right
thank you he's earned the righteous pass
yeah I mean he's still nice on the show
I'm gonna dip my toes in the water and
we'll see what happens you're gonna dip
okay you're gonna dip your butthole in
the flames and see what's up Through the
Fire and Flames my guy all right all
right
lots of people well I guess it's gonna
be saying lots of support for Zach in
the comments Bailey says Zacks proved
himself when he let Big Ed put mayo in
his hair and that's a long while ago
it's just a little more penguin brained
I'm getting [ __ ] you Ian
maybe Riddler no that does give me
penguin energy
not in a bad way but like if you look up
Danny DeVito's penguin there's a
resemblance what the [ __ ] what did I get
that pink [ __ ]
wait let me show you what I'm [ __ ] on
someone's lawn I'm serious let me see
like you've got like comparing me to
Oswald [ __ ] cobblepot here
I just think that if you look closely
and long enough you'll see what I'm
talking about
because like the hair and kind of like
yeah I just there's like a swag they do
both have a dark Aura there's a swag
you're saying I was thrown in a [ __ ]
River by my parents that didn't want me
because I was deformed you know a lot
about the Lord that's what I was saying
you're penguin bro no if anything I'm
Roman psionist I'm black yo penguins in
the chat ah there's so many no the
penguins are coming in the chat oh no
penguin brain this is this is worse than
[ __ ] eating the chip man
penguin and brain emojis penguin brain I
am Black Rose brain I just think that
there's yeah I'm Roman psionist dude
[ __ ] is that I don't know what you're
talking about [ __ ] a Johnny Depp
gangster movie about no you no no no no
no no that's black mass all right that's
what you said no I said black mask I'll
be making a black mass later tonight you
are always talking about Black Mass so
this is you you don't understand how's
that you Zack yeah dude I'm Roman
cyanics
this man doesn't have any skin stuff
yeah he's [ __ ] dude yeah I'm Whitey
Bulger brain so what do you guys okay
what do you guys have in common with
that's black skeleton what's the life
ask Ian I don't know he compared me to
him no he didn't I just said your
penguin brain no no this is off camera
[ __ ]
I'm always joking I'm always Joker brand
all right thank you guys [ __ ] all right
moving on thank you here's penguin by
the way
it looks great
bye Jesus Christ you're comparing me to
a four foot [ __ ]
creature no no not in this photo just
the one I showed all right well let's
move it on okay
um Zach you be whatever you want okay
that's that's the world we we live in
uh at the Joker Church
joke penguin church we got to get him
saying penguin church now moving on
prince Andrew is a pedo
Prince pedo I think
official title
oh it's not your ID
man I don't know
wow
[Music]
watch how they yank his ass back dude
[Music]
yes so um everyone remember this kid
when prince Andrew dies and then there's
like a 10 part documentary
we didn't see this coming
somebody donated five dollars and said
protester dragged from crowd after
heckling prince Andrew today thanks for
the heads up man
that's crazy wow that's wild look into
that I appreciate the five dollars we
need to look at you guys Google that
huh it's crazy
Chapel it's not your ID
[Music]
your Legend bro we'll remember you
forever
I just hope that one day I'm sorry Arab
world news I just hope when they do make
the documentary they invite him on
they'll get a little forward yeah
I saw various uh reports that was the
only video I had seen But of other
people who had protest signs or were
shouting things at the various events
related to this getting arrested which
is uh pretty cool pretty cool that you
can get arrested for
uh making fun of the royalty yeah it's a
very cool modern country I don't know
what they don't have the laws are in
England but in America you can I can say
whatever the [ __ ] I want about our
presidents which is great
this guy was arrested for uh
shouting abuse at Aunt prince Andrew
during the Queen's possession his name
is Rory
here's what he had to say somebody said
why is literally no one talking about
the protester that was dragged from the
crowd at the funeral with a million
questions and Stephen g a member for
four months thank you that's such an
interesting story that's breaking news
breaking news Stephen
we need to look into that a b Google
that I'm on it
is this the same Legend I think it is
wait what do you say let me see
need some more volume on this powerful
men should be allowed to commit sexual
crimes I think you're right Prince uh
you're the real that's the real Prince
yeah [ __ ] dude let's promote his ass
actually a brave Man by himself speaking
truth to power that's rock and roll
Rock and Roll Baby this man is out there
by himself
let's see what uh arable news analysis
is
hello everyone welcome to my channel
again we just watch it now young man was
filming shouting you are sick all the
men as the scariest Duke of York Prince
as he follows Queen offense
who called him sick old man before like
standards tackle him
prince Andrew was
Edinburgh in his suit after being a bank
right
a short huffle
ensued before the officer led him away
as he shouted disgusting and I have done
nothing wrong while in the background
shall about it
God saved the king
so okay at the end of the video don't
forget support me by like and document
science all right and a nice Fade Out on
the audio too appreciate
I liked it
together it's actually
there was people in the audience who
were like trying to fight the kid too
it's like dude what do you why do you
care about them here this was the other
one that I saw who elected him
interesting anti-monarchy protesters
arrested as Charles proclaimed Britain's
new king I don't think Charles is gonna
make it because he's got bailed sausage
fingers won and two he's just he doesn't
have the swag that Elizabeth had she was
like a hundred year Monarch she'd been
oversighted like all these huge
Monumental moments in British history
that people have a ton of sentimental
value and they see her they led her
through those times and so I understand
the emotional attachment to our to the
dearly departed and tragically too soon
taken from us Queen Elizabeth II but
Prince Charles is a [ __ ] weird inbred
looking elf man and I just don't see it
happening like he's just he's just kind
of a beast that is so true um and a king
or I guess he's still Prince Charles
right or is he King now
it's like King something it's like
president-elect King Charles or he's
technically he becomes king when she
dies the the moment
the old hag's heart stopped beating he
was the king there's some Doctrine there
that uh now get a load of this does this
look like a king to you I mean no this
looks like a guy who's [ __ ] uh
Spencer King he spends too much time you
know uh
side eyeing the young girls at like the
skater the bowling alley I don't know
I'm just saying that's how King looks
like
that's how they're supposed to look like
that is how most
oh Cheerio
darling Oh can you guys pop the video of
somebody left like a pen on his table
when he was signing something he freaked
out
oh that's not what you're talking about
uh
I want to see him with the jewels
does he get to put the jewels on
I get the jewels Betty yeah I was
learning about the crown jewels I didn't
realize that they were so
controversial stolen yeah no I mean
straight up literally just stolen from
Africa yeah the biggest diamond in the
they're all like super precious diamonds
within or not precious jewels with
Incredible history and story they have
names uh like that these these Jewels
have names do you understand what I'm
saying and they [ __ ] stole that [ __ ]
not even that long ago it's historically
speaking
and they're like not ours
super interesting
you know I mean what are we doing here
guys
[Music]
guys come on
this is just cruel at this point look at
these two
[Music]
not to be disrespectful
but God damn it it's happening
I just wanted to zoom in on that picture
again damn it
not allowed bear with me here folks look
just look at these two okay I mean what
are we doing
I don't want to they don't need to be
King ging and queening
nothing they want to be playing Mahjong
or [ __ ]
they want to be slake Jim rummy and slay
kinging a nice game of pan bocce ball
bocce ball that's what I'm saying these
Queen Elizabeth didn't know where she
was for the past decade
but the woman enjoys some [ __ ] Jello
and bingo
you know so true I'll leave and and
Charles I mean
this man could not get any redder
let's not put him through too much his
fingers are the size of same thickness
as
we know I won't he's got well-endowed
fingers
his fingers make me jealous even just
one chubber
probably a good lover though
sorry
disgusting I know I'm sorry you can also
probably not yeah no his breath smells
like [ __ ] you know his breath smells
like [ __ ]
this band is like one [ __ ]
[Music]
what sets this guy off he's like one
Mish shot at ski ball
what do you call it when you shoot the
plates out of the sky
I was skeet shooting he's like one skeet
shot off from having a heart attack I
mean look at the man he's so red
he definitely can't do the one chip
challenge oh my God
his fingers would explode it would take
him right out he'd be dead who's next I
just think it's time it's Time Queen
Elizabeth there's not going to be anyone
cooler than her in terms of like what
how much she presided over
let's just wrap it up I mean
right
yeah no absolutely the whole the whole
aristocracy thing
maybe it's just it's time
but okay it's none of my business I'm
I'm American you know
thank God for that that's the one thing
we got right
you know
here's the video of King Charles already
being a diva
on his first day as king
it's awesome
let's love this video
so he's sitting at a tiny little table
look how he's already being a diva about
everything come on come on come on
wait that's not it yeah it is no okay I
I know what you're talking about why are
you telling me it is that's not that was
the one that went viral it's not dude
it's a different video he has like a
whole [ __ ] panic attack over a big
he's sitting already he's sitting
but this one's good I haven't seen this
one
yeah
he's going come come get you off
here it is Dan
this is dedicated to Dan
here it is
the king watch this there's like a
Candlestick there are ink dipping thing
or I don't know what the [ __ ] it is but
she freaks the [ __ ] out right now
he goes
get it away
you see his face
look at his face when he's when he
realizes this is a gun take it
I'll have your head
oi I'll have your ad
we're kids we used to do this thing
called the [ __ ] voice when someone was
acting like them we just go and that's
what it made me think of when he was
Boy perfect way yeah it is but I don't
know it's pretty funny right he's like
really he's having a hard time with that
thing take that ah
there it is King Charles running a tight
ship already
gesturing for an aide panicking to help
him
oh my God what is this
people in the chat were saying Google
tampon gate and uh that sounds a little
bit the term tampon gate refers to a
leaked erotic phone call between Charles
and Camilla Parker who is now his wife I
believe that's the one he either cheated
on Princess Diana
it's about a call between the Royal
lovers the leak that went around here
I'm opening the article right now yo
there's a call of him talking about
tampons let's get that can we listen to
it uh in it Camila Parker mentioned I
can't stand a Sunday night without you I
can't start the week without you to
which Charles replied what about me the
problem is that I need you all week all
the time my God if I could live in your
pants it would be so much easier
uh live in your pants and then she said
what are you gonna do turn into knickers
well you're gonna turn into knickers no
no and he said into a tampon that would
be
did she laugh does it say if she laughed
or would she respond to that like is he
joking yeah he he laughed and she
laughed and he said Tampax he gave a
brand name hmm okay so maybe she's got a
bit of a human there a bit of a laugh
that's pretty gnarly though she goes she
goes you are a complete idiot laughs and
says oh what a wonderful idea
honestly am I right or wrong honestly
kind of a funny kind of humanizes them a
little bit kind of a Vibe for the for
the king it makes me think he's more
human but he was like I want to be a
tampon and she's like Anyway ignoring
that you said that
get out of here let's go wait we could
hear the audio clips yeah I'm looking
for it oh my God we're about to hear the
king sexting with his
mistress verbally sexting this is the
first time in history
we've been able to I'm looking for it it
it's just coming up with a bunch of
podcasts reacting to it I just want the
damn original phone call are you on
YouTube yeah I'm looking on Google Now
they probably scrub that [ __ ]
well I'm not moving until we find that
damn okay
what exactly
scandalous phone call yeah King King
Charles he's in there I guess he's
active Prince Charles
would it be interesting do you think
maybe
is that good
if his member was shoved up as his
fingers guys
secured
I'm just gonna just said I'm not like
not like following the release of the
raunchy phones I'm just because I'm
trying to find the dance I got it you
found it thank you Olivia
here we go guys the first time in human
history we're hearing a king sexting
fascinating
thank you
go off King oh my goodness here it is
Charles this is real yo
how did this get leaked
was someone listening it's a good
question
this is the audio of Prince Charles and
Camilla having the most boring phone sex
where he told her he wanted to be her
tampon
this was recorded in 1989 and released
in 1993.
I need audio audio audio
it's not paused it's playing there's no
audio
audio
[Music]
this is like weird like spyware spycraft
[ __ ] like
it's not even a phone tap it's like
there's a bug in the ceiling or some
[ __ ] yeah maybe
[Music]
um
that is just not sexy King I'll fill up
your tank pink is that saying he wants
to like [ __ ] her yeah I guess I will
fill up your tank with my jizz
you'll be like a car I'll make you like
an automobile that runs on my semen
right now
I will be giving you
unleaded premium semen F to fit up your
tank
[Music]
um
you'll be like a diesel engine craving
my unleaded premium
you're a big lore you naughty Lori
you big naughty Lori
all right
that is a main section wait what she
looks just like Diana
wait who am I looking at Diana yeah
this is this is two
I don't know they all look the same how
do they look the same they're all the
same level so the juiciest bits and here
is the that can't be Diana she's with
Charles oh wait she was married or
married
quote okay
[Music]
you know what it's kind of [ __ ] yeah
he's just wasn't as bad as honestly he's
having a laugh yeah
that's that's that I'm down with to be
honest the tank uh fill your tank up was
way worse
darling
you're like a cruise ship I just your
tank is so big
[Laughter]
I could just fill you and fill you all
day
[Music]
all right we should I've got to be 30
minutes by now yeah we can we let's do
it so let's thank our sponsor hellofresh
then let's just get into this whole
nightmare
um I'm just seeing real fast if there's
anything else I want to talk about today
or we can probably move it to Wednesday
yeah we can move all this stuff to
Wednesday
all right guys
let's just thank our sponsor hellofresh
we love them
we know them
shout out all football Troopers who love
and support hellofresh just like all we
do hellofresh you get farm fresh
pre-portioned ingredients and seasonal
recipes delivered right to your doorstep
oh that's the one you cooked in that
look maybe oh yeah it looks like it yeah
it looks so slightly different it's not
the one you put
it's the same recipe but no where's the
one you could uh oh yeah sorry that's
not the exact one yeah uh yeah I want to
see the ABIA cooked one of these I want
to hear about it
um
yo Prince Charles looks like Mad Max
what look at this
[Music]
boy
Let's uh let's stick to the address okay
right right right right right cam sent
it to me
uh Prince Charles loves Hello fresh
in fact
he would order it every day
I'm sure of it here's Amy's yeah tell me
about this burger
I was really good Lena made it made it
quick and uh it's delicious and then I
sent you guys a photo I asked if you
guys had any uh advice from my
photography you send it and I go can you
get more angles he's like I already bit
into it I was like why'd you send it
then why'd you even ask I was making a
joke and I think you're actually gonna
ask yeah let's get some I wanted some
action shots because I knew we'd talk
about it right let's get some fly over
some slow-mo all we need is like you
know in the burger commercial they
always like Drop The Patty yeah down and
then like the lettuce and it all like
kind of assembles this was your this was
your opportunity to redeem your burrito
I'm proud of that brand but I mean you
know Lena what was the what was in the
burger
it was just the meat and then on top was
like um what was the baby the onions
that they were fried they were fried
onions but it came in a packet that way
it's good and it was so it was super
convenient after work just made it so
quickly
makes it I eat it
I love that
um
guys
it's affordable it's fun
it's easy
that's why we're now skipping trips to
the grocery store to go to Hello fresh
America's number one meal kit now more
than ever we're all looking for ways to
save money in fact hellofresh is
actually 25 less expensive than takeout
and it's even cheaper than grocery store
shopping too
um also
fall is per I'm trying to find
here hellofresh works with your schedule
the plans are flexible and you can
change your meal preferences update your
delivery day and even change your
address with just a few Taps on the
hellofresh app yeah apparently if you go
on vacation you can have them delivered
to your spot it's no problem it's easy
but guys the the offer here is
incredible go to hellofresh.com
h3tv16 and use the code h3tv16 for 16
free meals across seven boxes and three
gifts
at telefresh.com h3tv16
use the code h3tv 16 for 16 free meals
thank you thank you to a hellofresh
America's number one meal care
and now
the moment we've all been waiting for I
think Zach should go first
just dip your toes I have to do music
and sounds and yeah
if we could cover you baby's done it
Flocka I suppose
just do well I think it'll be if you
guys I'm gonna I'll just be I'll explain
my rationale I think if you see anyone
else reacting to this you're definitely
not gonna do it so I just want to get a
little piece in your mouth before you
bail
[ __ ] you in
but it works it fits on you perfect
wow here let's do it let's just do a
little nibble right
and
fine okay I'll tell you what if you say
no I won't bring it up again right now
I'm coming over there thanks bro
just the camera
Zach is gonna come be our first
recipient of the chip challenge
recipient's a good word
recipient I'm Gonna Fill your time I
thought you were gonna say victim and
recipients are much better word
and Ethan you'll be participating of
course I will yes of course yeah
absolutely that's what I said I'm not
David dobrik I'm right in the trenches
with you guys okay
now this is again once again are you
okay Dan we Gucci audio audio once again
this is the one chip challenge
2022. do you want to hit the Pepto
before you go take a look let me take a
look at your Rolex never seen up close
damn you cleaned that regularly like
looks shiny give it a bath every day
looks beautiful thanks man how do you
wash it just with soap and water Dawn
soap in a microfiber towel
nice thank you do you need to take it in
for like maintenance uh frequently or
not
um yeah
fillets
um maintenance
what's wrong you don't like the Flocka
No flock is good which flock of Love
yeah [ __ ] yeah look I don't know it
doesn't need to be like every like you
need like a watch Master to Tinker with
it take it into Rolex service I don't
know it's usually every it's a long time
it's a long time okay okay you have a
small gnome-like man with his glasses
with like four magnifying glasses on him
Swiss man looks something they live in a
tree yes you might want to correct glove
I've seen watchmakers on Tick Tock and
they're it's actually so cool what they
do like I don't know if you've seen this
guy they like um the Chinese dude yeah
yeah he like uh re restores old Rolexes
it's so amazing that his work
here it is now I don't know if this is
an official entry are we doing an
official entry
yeah yeah yeah yeah
because yeah I think
you have the whole thing for an official
entry
we're gonna I'm gonna test the waters
we'll see how it goes yeah
yeah okay so you just say mer when
you're done you're out you can have the
milk the water whatever the point is
yeah we're gonna go for as long as we
can and Ian are you still getting the
stopwatch here
yeah okay and we're gonna have a
scoreboard here I know this is very off
the rails but um can you play that sweet
milk somebody
uh yeah let me find it and do you still
have the the music going on
the right side yeah yeah I got it by the
way I will say you have a fully intact
chip based on feeling which is I guess
that's a good sign it's a sign of high
on it's chipped up it's bricked up just
like those Charles fingers did you rip
this I yes I did okay I just I was just
got it started and I'll give it to you
are you doing the whole chip I'm going
to test the water okay because that
sounds good to me too now that now that
this is starting I see Superstar you
know that movie yeah Molly Shannon where
she's like dipped toes in the pool or
you can either jump in I'm dipping my
toes I'm committing to eating the whole
challenge just to say there's no dip I'm
just saying you do what you want because
you're you're on the fence that's fine
the challenge is that everyone who wants
to compete you take the chip you put it
in you chew it down now you do whatever
you want I'm just saying now everybody
is saying don't use water which yeah
that's what I've always heard too is
that water doesn't really help with
spicy so uh I personally have found that
ice water does help me a lot room tap
water is not good but ice water when I'm
trying to cool my mouth is good just to
sit on an ice cube in my experience okay
well we do have milk here too sweet milk
it does say time without maybe get some
ice Lena do we have ice so we can I mean
ice and milk and water is all good sweet
milk just pretend this Graphics no I
need to yeah I definitely recommend
hitting the Pepto foreign
yeah and again I I think it's important
that we protect our our stomachs here is
that enough
yeah whatever you want are we
waterfalling this or what what's the
best route
um yeah waterfall is [ __ ] yeah we'll
just drink it and we'll figure it out in
the next one we can wash it just rinse
it out after yeah
all right so the pepto's down it tastes
like
looks like the Pink Panther's like like
jism or something you know it reminds me
of like before you get like uh
there's some procedures we have to drink
like radioactive [ __ ] so they can see
your veins all right that's what's going
on here pet scan yeah how's your day
going going good good I'm I'm I'm
concerned because I have a definitely an
open sore on my throat so that's gonna
wait what
well because I'm because I'm sick I'm
coughing I have like active phlegm
sounds like a horrible idea then we're
finding this out now
what are you talking about I've been
talking about it for like a week no I
know that what's wrong with it an open
store I don't know anything happens when
you have a sore throat it's like tender
tissue yeah it's inflamed flame that
makes sense oh [ __ ] all right Jackie so
let's take a look you could take the
chip out here
dip those toes so uh just so that we are
fair and consistent here can you show it
does the stopwatch start the second the
trip that starts his mouth or hits his
mouth I think so yeah but but only but
only if they finish the whole thing so
let me take a look at this pull it up
for the camera maybe we could get oh my
god get a close-up of this this thing is
coded
it looks like almost like moldy or fun
or just because it's coated so heavily
um in Mossy oily powder [ __ ] yeah no and
then the active ingredient here once
again
that is is a
Carolina Reaper pepper and Scorpion
Chili Pepper
how about that smells like but it has
sea salt on it oh flavor oh any like
it's nice it paprika any uh garlic no oh
well no no hey Emerald you know it's
blue corn sunflower oil
pepper sea salt blue one
what did you ask how's the smell it
doesn't smell spice huh I'm not touching
it smell it I won't like I won't [ __ ] I
didn't want that near my face until it's
my time all right well I since this
broke off I'm I'm just gonna so this
isn't gonna count as an entry until you
if you once you start chewing I think
start the timer but this okay you go
ahead and try it Zack
oh my God it's just a
you know what I'm happy you're even
doing that I'm not gonna complain I'm
doing I'm this is my dipping toes okay
yeah Flocka you're not even gonna eat
the whole thing
no don't don't you feel on the ground my
dogs are here
yeah flock like the tiniest chunk oh my
God
did you get all the crumbs yeah I don't
want I'll Shredder to die it was just a
little okay oh my God
oh
just careful please keep it on the table
oh my god dude
some jokers in chat
that's Joker brain right now oh I feel
it in my thoracic cavity no Pandora like
you're not sternum are you gonna finish
it no dude what the [ __ ] ah
dude I took a little bite what the [ __ ]
huh if you're not gonna finish that
obviously we'll just move on because we
do have a show to do here and uh
you know not to be rude but
stop it right now you know I not to be
rude or anything but uh we have people
here lined up to eat the whole chip and
uh
yeah you probably will
so we might have to just you know make
some space for them
oh yeah so thank you Zach everybody
just cut it out right now dude
all righty oh thanks buddy
oh can I have some milk or something
yeah of course help yourself yeah yeah
that's that's the idea thanks Zach
thanks for coming on all right
all right get in the boot yes
we gotta hold we got all 10 people here
that are trying to do the game they can
wait you can't sit here the whole damn
time you had like one crumb yeah [ __ ]
what if I take another bite
you gotta just full set we need you back
here Zach you hear what's happening with
the flockas it's getting out of hand you
you gotta full send it this this is your
moment to go full milk I can't do that
all right then then that's fine I'm
sorry thank you Zacky thank you all
right this is not good I appreciate that
yeah just just safely dispose of that
thank you buddy all right well you know
what I'm proud of Zach he tried it out
stop saying I'm giving dobric Vibes I'm
going to eat the damn chip
hmm all right well Zach So based on that
one crumb Zach kind of had a meltdown
what are you guys thinking uh I don't
know who wants to go next anyone want to
volunteer
I'll bite the bullet all right all right
and what a hero
so I guess you could just put n what
Zach doesn't get a time for that just
put an a well how about we just put like
an asterisk
and then maybe like I just want to track
the time like okay I still want to track
the time you just had a little baby bite
fair enough fair enough he gets an
asterisk
Mickey Mouse ring all right so cam go
ahead join us here please uh we have a
worthy competitor here in cam grants
ladies and gentlemen
give it up give it up now cam how are
you feeling go ahead grab one of those
boxes you can start opening it
um Lena can you do me a favor
front
table because I just want to I just want
to protect the doggies
okay
Maybe
it's still dying how are you doing from
that cut to Zach ah my throat is like
thank you are those tears screaming down
your face
exactly how you what's going on with you
talking about I'm not in a good place
right now holy [ __ ] oh no but this is
very interesting because you had like
I don't do good with spicy but one tiny
crumb I mean is this making you nervous
cam or yes I mean I'm very nervous right
now but I'm trying to stay Mr Freeze
brain right now and just
cool like Mr Freeze
chill out
okay I'm careful you already touched the
crumbs on the table technically with
your hands I did [ __ ] where's those I
mean yeah yeah just be safe
the last thing you want is that spicy in
your eyes
oh Zach are you okay you've got milk and
Ice you're doing okay you want some more
Pepto no
um
we might need more Pepto I'm just saying
heads up
I foresee me drinking that old bottle
dude [ __ ] that oh my God
to walk me through what you're
experiencing uh Zach my like like I said
my thoracic cavity
never heard that before it's a medical
term
um throat my tongue
my lips can I recommend just just toss
some ice around in your mouth that helps
me okay
we're not done really spicy stuff I just
keep something cold in my mouth to get
through it you know I'll join in a
second there Zach
Pepsi helps if I'm being honest cam is
throwing down a little Pepto-Bismol oh
thank you so much
got this camera you're [ __ ] stunt
dude all right cam has is locked and
loaded with the Pepto
all right hold on we are opening the
chip chip unboxing video here yeah I'm
worried about these doggies
yeah I don't are dogs affected by spicy
I'm sure oh yeah yeah yes because I know
there's some animals that don't
oh did it break like yeah it didn't fall
oh no yeah wait actually there's another
engine here we go there we go okay we're
in now just be very careful opening it
please over the table thank you so much
you can trust me
oh my God another full chip hold that up
wow
damn
I wish you guys could see a close-up of
this can we I mean it really is
something it does smell spicy Zach I
don't know what you're talking about
I didn't smell spice it smells very
spicy so maybe a recommendation for me
if you want to eat the whole thing
I think if it touched your lips it's
gonna hurt a lot so maybe break it up in
half okay so you can get it all in it
doesn't touch your lips all right that's
maybe what I'll do
I'm gonna take your advice I trust you
on that look at that oh yeah that's a
perfect shot that thing is evil man can
you see how yeah
GE first crush is your tongue blue Zach
it's supposed to turn your mouth blue I
don't know if you ate enough yeah no all
right well all right Cameron's the first
one brave brave
wonderful cam wish me luck guys good
luck buddy let's get some ice cubes and
chat for me oh wait wait
oh
all right all right you good Dan yep all
right here we go just as soon as it's
all in his his mouth you can get it
started
oh Cam he crunched it all in there
[ __ ] Legend and I take off your
gloves okay so you don't get your face
oh my God he's already seems to all
right you have spice on your fingers you
can just put that in there Savage Oh my
God can is already visibly having a hard
time with that I heard it tastes really
bad is that what it tastes like [ __ ]
okay okay are you okay
no oh my god oh Mission Boston I'm proud
of you [ __ ]
oh my God it's very dry can I at least
hit a milk jug yes okay absolutely
absolutely just to get it down I think
so yeah I guess just that I took a
little zip yeah making the the spice
liquid open your mouth so you could see
the blue tongue yeah
oh [ __ ]
can I hear Let Me Get You adapters you
have a little bit on your lips and I
don't want that to sit there
okay so careful with your hands you
still have spice on them talk to us
um what am I supposed to say you know it
sucks I'm feeling the heat is rising
right now
um
I'm scared oh I'm scared
my heartbeat is rising oh God my throat
is
feeling the fire can I ask you do you
think that it's ethical to sell these on
Amazon to anyone I mean voluntarily but
I knew what I was getting into
there's tears coming down my eyes right
now oh my God watch your eyes don't
touch your eyes yeah okay but you're
doing I mean listen you're on the path
holy [ __ ] you look like an anime you can
I see God right now dude cam I'm
watching you turn red man holy [ __ ]
what's my timer at right now you're at
uh almost two minutes minute 45. this is
super impressive I think
I think you're doing amazing I I think
you might be setting a really high Bar
for a bar real high you see this yeah
you're shaking
is your mouth just [ __ ] right now yes
yeah well
uh tummy uh the thoracic pain you have
the thoracic pain whatever Zach just
said it was I'm trying to go for three
minutes right now Jurassic paint
you have 50 seconds left dude I am so
impressed yes I am yeah I know cam says
he's suffering but you are handling this
like an absolute Madman
a lot of pain
oh my God yeah yeah I'm feeling good
though I feel okay you know I feel alive
certainly feel alive
um
um I see the tears still got 20 seconds
man if you want that three minute you're
right there you might be winning this
thing dude yeah we usually go with spicy
food too right yeah I'm okay with spicy
food but this is a this is a creature
right oh that now I'm really scared I'm
not as my creativity is definitely down
for my vocabulary because I can't really
describe it because I'm in a lot of pain
right [ __ ] really really coherently
but I'm usually funnier and this is not
this is taking out the funny three
minutes the pain glands oh there we go
[ __ ] bailing okay so go ahead and
stop and uh stop okay
[Applause]
wash your hands with soap because I
don't want you to get in your eyes or
anything okay any other recommendations
any uh just wash your hands with soap
put some ice in your mouth and just I
like to keep the ice in my mouth it just
told it till it passes
keep chugging them
you can come back and talk more I just
want you to wash your hands so you don't
get it in your eyes thank you oh well
drink some ice and whatever else you
need I think we might need more milk
guys we only have one
cam yeah
um who instacarted it is that Lena yeah
I think it's more yeah can you get some
we're gonna need middle yeah we're gonna
burn through that milk we're gonna need
two more of those and another Pepto got
it maybe two more pepto's okay
so this this [ __ ] is insane like
this is insane people saying ice cream
you know what that's a pretty good idea
get some ice cream too Lena yeah ice
cream cam what kind of ice cream you
like
[Music]
what kind of ice cream do you like
cookies a cream I like mint and Chip
anyone else want to put in an ice cream
order well
I mean the car's just gonna grab I feel
like they just grab whatever I mean
we'll grab a specifically yeah they
usually come through yeah okay good so
Cameron is wow his first showing what do
you think about that Zach I mean you've
been you've had a taste for the
for the spies
but Cameron or some Jacqueline I'm here
oh yeah so what do you think cam you
want to come join us it's a goat man I
don't do well with spicy I've never done
well with spicy yeah I get that some
people for whatever reason to be
completely honest with you I'm kind of a
little short of breath I feel like my
throat's like closed
people are seeing yourself uh cam how's
it going everybody
okay okay saga's literally dying wait
Zach
was that his throat uh feels like it's
closing up wait are you serious yeah
you feel like you're suffocating not
suffocating but um poor camera just hit
the whole damn thing do you need a more
drink are you drinking something get
somebody drinking Pepsi I'll live I just
want that to be okay how about some milk
uh yeah I'll take some more all right
let me get you some get get bring a a
glass of ice milk please thank you very
much that's that's ice milk I think is
what you're gonna want Zach please
exactly my throat's climbing up yeah you
might be allergic to something anyway
yeah I didn't hear
I believe that was one of the warnings
they said uh if you yeah if you are
experiencing difficulty breathing
fainting or extended nausea are you
having difficulty breathing slightly oh
great should we I'll be okay we're
cutting this
thank you
we're cutting this thing short here well
okay Zach if you're dying please tell us
okay okay I'll do it on camera this is a
live show and that would be a probably a
strike for me so it'd be pretty badass
though I want to get I want to get you
off camera before I get a strike Zach is
going to bring down people saying stop
Pepsi by the way I don't know
yeah so cam how are you doing you got a
Cactus Cooler
your eyes are blood red I I'm not
feeling good but you know I'm I feel
like I'm better than Zach right now I
hope Zach's okay
holy [ __ ]
[Laughter]
no dude your face is seen at all
I hope I wasn't cringe what no you were
a [ __ ] hero I was super impressed I
don't think I can take down that was
insane I'm telling you guys right now
everyone taking part this sucks oh oh
yeah do you have any tips I've never
been so glad to have diarrhea in my life
you have any tips for people coming
behind you
um
say your prayers say your prayers well
Cam's on the leaderboard at just over
three minutes so maybe
I
think
is it I think there's a few
I promise Olivia I wouldn't so all right
well I told them I didn't believe him
we'll see how that works well the views
people are piling in people are enjoying
the show so at least that get your heart
out David dobrik
um who wants to go next I we've got
Nina Nina
you know are you surprised to see this
like courageous Brave it's like she's
jumping right into the gunfire she she
likes to test herself so
real girl boss hours right now real good
often please I don't know if we
acknowledge
yeah Lena's been helping everybody else
and she might need extra milk can I see
Zach's camera I just want to take a look
at yeah you you look okay Zach you doing
okay yeah doing a little better yeah
okay good I think your throat closing up
is likely just it being super irritated
right I don't think you're having like a
allergic reaction no at least I'm gonna
manifest you not I think I'm panicking
and then cam you doing okay
he's gone I hear him in the bathroom
he just dug his own grave and flung
himself in Lena welcome wow so are you
excited to do that yeah and I tastes
spicy but I'm excited for the thrill oh
my God Lena ladies and gentlemen this is
incredible
Lena you like to play horror games are
you you're a thrill seeker of some sort
yeah you can say that that explains why
you're married to A.B the bad boy
okay yeah
um
so Lena is opening the coffin
now okay what's the spiciest food you'd
usually eat
um I like moderate nothing like too much
too much yeah I can't do it and my eyes
get look really watery and stuff okay
well Lena here we go this is this is
something
all right let me uh get my clock ready
here okay once again I just hit uh such
bravery by these folks here cam Atlanta
like like I told Cam I think you don't
want it on your lips I know that for
sure I'm gonna piece it Selena's gonna
cut it in half here but yeah cam really
inspired me to just do it
you can do it three times just so you
can get it in there so I this is the
whole thing and then I think once you
munch it it's gonna be pretty dry so if
you need something to get it down okay
that's totally fine did you take any uh
Pepto in advance oh you don't want Pepto
no I think I'll be I'll be fine I'll get
you a glass if you want she doesn't like
drinking after people no it's fine I
have my milk that's fine all right I'm
just gonna jump in the pool all right
here goes Lena ladies and gentlemen
oh my it's all in he's in the clock is
chewing
okay no I'm not I'm just gonna throw
this out she's chilling she's nodding
she's loving it what wait whoa whoa whoa
whoa Lena goes hmm
Cameron was already like full-blown
panicking at this point and she's not
even going for a drink to wash it down
oh my God
wow this is insane wow
oh [ __ ] are you [ __ ] serious right
now
she's stunting on these kids maybe not
it's not that bad
what is happening here ladies and
gentlemen I'm getting a little hot cam
said he puked in the bathroom oh no more
no okay all right all right
um can you grab her a tissue please
because you have some on your lips I
just want you to go to tries yeah don't
okay so is it still not that bad what
are we feeling now I just feel hot you
feel hot can we see the tongue the blue
tongue
yeah the blue tongue
oh so
yeah it's not that bad are you serious I
am are you [ __ ] scared I'm gonna beat
Cam said that I can wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait say that again
just look at the camera and say that
again
I'm embarrassed my lips are all colored
but
it's not that bad oh my God it's not
you're gonna make us all look like such
babies I like it what oh stop that's
like what people ask her how's it like
being married to me it's not that bad
not that bad I thought it would be worse
I mean oh my God I feel like you need to
hang in there beat Kim you gotta stay in
there
he's just over three minutes I cannot
believe what I'm seeing she didn't even
wash it down
and just just as a reminder when we were
doing the pregnancy pain uh segment Lena
oh Stein valiantly she's like she like
laughed it was like tickling it was
thickering all the rest of us were who
are you my girl yeah
he's a machine do you need like um
you need to get some more extreme sports
or something maybe maybe I mean it's not
it's
or it's tough but it's not as bad as I
expected from Cab's reaction she just
got called out you just got called a
baby cam wait I'm curious he's still
puking your Jam's still uh
you got it you got it so you feel hot
your mouth doesn't hurt it's hot it's
just hot yeah okay okay but she says not
that you guys are getting a little
watery but you got it three minutes and
eight seconds I cannot believe what I'm
seeing Lena is officially crowned you're
the new Queen
[ __ ] Elizabeth she's dead and gone Queen
Lina the first all right you'll be
passing uh cam in 10 seconds okay but
remember you can push forward if you
want the crown just go oh yeah I can go
longer what the [ __ ] is this baby I came
this far I want to win all right you now
have the record you are you are in world
record territory now all right so so
talk to me you know I'm just hot and
like kind of sweaty do I look sweaty no
you look I mean you look great yeah it's
not what I'm worried about I'm feeling
it in my stomach now is that good is bad
it's not good feeling yeah yeah coming
from Lena I think that's really bad yeah
I definitely had like a delayed effect
sure but um I got this
well listen don't I mean don't push
yourself too hard dude you are you have
the championship Lena's gonna give birth
and be like it's not that bad
what we've seen well Lena's absolutely
smashed Cam's record she's at four
minutes now four in a second uh the bar
is so high it's so so high there's four
minutes oh sorry to drool a little bit
but that's okay you know it's it is what
it is
so tell me Lena were you a good student
in high school
[Laughter]
oh my God she goes it's not that bad
she's like having a she's like
transported to another day a little bit
dizzy now but oh um okay that was a good
student yeah good student good good job
she got a scholarship to college yeah
what was your GPA at high school okay
3.9 or 4.0 yeah very good wow she's
smartly working what did you major in oh
it's just medical yeah I did um a
Bachelor of Science in Psychology oh
yeah
so what's your take on Zach then
um
[Laughter]
he deserves an Applause for for doing it
yeah no I mean just on his brain on his
psychiatric condition overall yeah just
like everything that's wrong with it
because you have more credentials than
uh any of us I don't think anything's
wrong with him
um he likes the Joker brain meme so
you know go for it go for it are you
saying that it's just a meme and that
he's not actually a joker brain
my me myself I haven't seen anything
Joker brain oh
is that bad thing I'm sorry
you're being real I mean Joker Lena's
too sweet Joker is like killing people
on the train you know yeah okay you're
at five and a half minutes I mean I
don't think anyone's going this long but
you stop when you want okay I feel like
we should call it you're gonna call that
yeah
as soon as you take a sip the clock ends
yeah but should I just go to six I feel
like someone's gonna try to beat me
you're right there it's up to you I
think can we get some I do you want ice
in your milk this is fine okay all right
he doesn't want to bother this it's fine
you're like this is fine meme you are
literally literally in a burning Forest
right now
I
hate you
you're a champion she's at six minutes
wait Kim how are you feeling okay
whenever you're ready okay so hold on
and stop it six minutes
wow and all my days
[Applause]
so I recommend to what go wash your
hands okay real soapy and if you could
just give me a tissue yeah
Lena thank you for the gifted thank you
for the gifted okay thank you guys Lena
what a gift she's giving us yeah I am
just I am stunned I am odd I think
Lena's our our group Daredevil I think
we got to stay here
you're shaking oh
Jesus she's gotten ice in her milk
she seems to be suffering a lot more
she's letting on yeah I mean on a brave
face I mean whatever though like
oh she's she's running to the to wash
her hands I mean just put that in your
mouth and say it's not that bad it'd be
fun to check up on her I think it just
it takes a bit to kick in such a warrior
Olivia don't go over here she's a
warrior
oh my God
oh you know what so cam you know why he
a cam
yes sir so how are you feeling you sound
like you're fine is that uh yeah I feel
good now oh my God it didn't last that
long I mean I'm I'm a little more used
to spice I think but uh also Lena's a
champion too but yeah Lena's puking now
yeah it's oh my God yeah it's it's I
think this is gonna be the uh that's
probably better for your body I frankly
yeah I was gonna say puking it is
probably the best move because you
coming out the other end not gonna be
that's burn coming out I can't think
it's gonna come out both ends
anyways did it burn when you puked
camera yeah I mean everything's still
burning when you're puking anyways so
it's just another burn
um Lena's puking now I think yeah
everything in your body is just
screaming get the [ __ ] out right now
when when you have that in your system
yeah I'll say um yeah Lena for Creator
Clash someone said I know we got to get
her in there
the fact that lean is puking that that
that that says a lot because I I think
she's a she's a gladiator
wow
yeah this sucks dude
yeah this oh it's dude I'm scared I'm
really scared of the wound in the back
of my throat
I feel like if I start choking on it
because I'm coughing I'm done for cam
does your head hurt at all
excuse me sorry um everything hurts yeah
my head is like just like
oh all right well
um people saying lean is poison ivy
brain yeah is she okay Amy
did she yak
no she didn't oh no would you would you
lie to protect her dignity no I would
say if she threw up she didn't puke no
okay she's like well I feel I'm like are
you all right she goes yeah I'm just
trying to get it out she oh she's trying
to puke oh no she I don't know she said
I'm trying to breathe it out whatever
that means can she come where we could
see her I don't want her to like Drop
Dead on the bathroom no I totally leave
the door she's in the kitchen right now
I should start walk over the kitchen
people are saying I'm gonna bail I'm not
gonna bail I promise you guys I'm gonna
eat this [ __ ] chip all right I'm
terrified now
Venus said it's not that bad
can I go next absolutely
I kind of want to see what she's going
no in fact you need to go help again
no no
she puked a little bit can you talk you
could come sit next to me maybe Lena oh
you didn't do like a full Yak camera
just a little bit it just was like a
little bit of spit it felt like spittle
oh so even yak
did like stomach bile come out or just
spit
oh so you guys didn't puke neither of
them this is the most
and so did it burn coming up or it's not
coming up just like
feels like it's on fire
my whole mouth my lips
but you look like you're doing great you
feel like you're on top of it though
yeah yeah it's definitely manageable and
I'm chewing on some ice so that helped
too this WOW Lena ladies and gentlemen
Unstoppable for you yeah I'm telling you
we got to put you up to more stunts
because this is nuts I gotta put your
ass on an extra it's not easy I'm not
saying it's easy but
Lina not that bad yeah well I signed
about that Jack it's not that bad not
sound like that somebody in the chat was
asking if love has one um you you did
order one right love
I ended up not ordering it because I
knew it wouldn't come in time
um Zach
sorry Jack call me don't be a [ __ ]
and I'm like I'm not I'm gonna eat it
did you type that attack I don't know
what you're talking about wait where did
I see that oh no I don't see any message
saying what somebody just said that to
me weird
he deleted it at least that didn't then
he did Zach I didn't even get my turn
yet I'm gonna call me a [ __ ] you've had
like a [ __ ] crumb
come on if I thought I was gonna die man
all right so uh a b welcome to the
welcome you hit the PIP though yeah okay
how you feeling I'm terrified you're
terrified absolutely terrified yeah but
but you're brave and you're willing to
do it for the show and that's what we
love yes and I kind of want to see what
Lena's going through because you have a
what is this cute little glass you've
got there with the ice in it I don't
know who's that's not mine can you pull
it put that up where's this dainty
little thing come from
oh
all right so Abe go ahead and open it up
um
you're struggling there's a pair of
scissors uh in front of the laptop now
yeah no he's just there you go I'm just
scared okay so AV is opening the coffin
can you hear my throat is kind of raspy
I think I'm gonna choke on this and I
might actually die
I may not be able to breathe
so we've got a big fat juicy one of a b
so again I you can do it however you
want but I recommend like I have to
everybody to avoid the lips as much as
possible okay so like split it and then
do it yeah split it into small enough
pieces you can just put it in your mouth
at once you know
so a b is uh
okay so he's got it all into thirds or
fourths fourths okay all right all right
Wanna Be Ready start the timer
baby's crunching away remember you can
you can toss it back if you need
something to
if it's too dry for you
yeah
I mean Lena is Nobody Does it like her
she didn't even drink the toss it back
I'm freaking believable
you go to hell my buddy we need to we
need to see your eyes yeah yeah okay so
just be careful get this I know you're
probably I'll help you out here yeah
okay
oh yeah you had gloves on you're okay
okay all right talk us through it I know
you
I know you have a hard time with spicy
so this is a horrible time this is this
is pretty good what what you're doing
you your glasses visit the light yeah
yeah okay
yeah so ABS now lean at this point said
it's not that bad do you agree or
disagree it's the worst pain in my life
okay okay all right that doesn't sound
good
uh not that bad do we have ah oh my God
you okay you remember you could have a
drink of ice anytime
okay he's drinking yeah good idea can we
get him some you can stop the timer yeah
stop the timer Ian
yeah you get him some ice milk that's
the ticket I think well you know what
the [ __ ] you can sit with this though uh
maybe if you can
let me give me that milk please do you
have um it's not that bad sound bite
Zach you can hit us with
okay so a b seems yeah Olivia has a few
phobia but but he's not gonna puke right
baby
I don't know if I'm gonna live yeah
all right Amy's out of here that's not
bad Lena uh
can you believe Lena a B I mean this
this girl is like not oh he's pouring
Pepto-Bismol in his mouth he's drinking
milk with ice he's not doing well
it's the one chip challenge he's running
dude I'm telling you it's awful can you
can somebody follow him follow him with
the camera Dan let's get a Chase cam
's following Amy let's
let's get a look here what what's going
on here was that soap
what is that looks like almond milk or
some type of coffee oh okay I thought he
was putting
Dawn in his mouth
that might kill it honestly
yeah well he did it
he did it
that's a brave man right there
Lena's still dying she got the fan on
oh [ __ ]
he didn't puke he just spit water out
no it's just water he's just rinsing his
mouth out
you're okay
you're very sensitive to vomit huh
how long have you been like that
really
there's never a moment
someone puke on you or something
oh so that gave you a little bit of a
thing
whoa who was it that puked on you
yeah couldn't get on the mic here
I do remember his name
his first name was Donovan he said let
me just get this stuff everywhere thank
you he sat in the middle seat
in my elementary school carpool and he
vomed chicken all over himself ew and we
had to drive all the way home so it was
what was it the smell that got you the
and ever since that moment you're very
sensitive
I remember being very sensitive in that
moment to it but it could just be that
there was a kid with vomit I think I
think yeah it was a transformative
memory yeah
um can we cut to a b
yeah he's in the bathroom with the door
closed oh [ __ ] yeah can you get in there
Dan just you could talk
you okay
I'll go check Lena seems like she's
doing pretty well
Pepto-Bismol it just feels like a bad
stomach ache right now yeah Lena's going
for the Pepto
drink lots of Pepto guys that's the good
[ __ ] we got more on the way right okay
yeah wait a b did it
yeah yeah you missed it yeah you missed
all that yeah I was just watching my
[ __ ] accusing stuff yeah no AB did it
he got it all down it was he didn't make
it very long but uh a minute yeah
everyone saw that if anybody that steps
up as a champion today oh dude mad
respect for ab I know he's he has a
really hard time with the spicy
but prayers in the chat phrase I just
can't get over Lena I mean that that was
unbelievable I'm just floored you're the
reason I'm here today
okay well you want to be next to Olivia
you're sitting here for Christ's sake
let's just get it let's just do it all
right go ahead grab your coffin and the
gloves so Olivia are you good with spicy
what's your what's your uh I'm okay with
it I like grew up eating friends
Hot Cheetos but like I could never eat a
whole bag by myself
I could today oh [ __ ] but I couldn't
grow enough yeah I was like you're in
trouble
um how do we feel about me eating half
of it and just not participating in the
competition
um I feel fat you do whatever you want
yeah do whatever okay
we'll still time you and everything I'll
just you'll get an asterisk I will say I
will say I don't think eating half is
gonna reduce the pain at all you know
what you're right because I think once
it's in there it's in there but you do
you and we all we love it we love
everything here I mean just a little
crumb [ __ ] me up I mean let's be
honest nobody's beating Lena anyway I
know
so we got the coffin open
that was scary
okay
oh you smelled it smells bad yeah no
thank you I'll wait
okay so you got one big chippy and just
like I've been recommending everybody
Olivia to break it up so you can get it
in there but whatever you like I don't
know if I can do this whole thing
okay whatever you're comfortable with
just eat over the table please thank you
I just want the doggies to get it that's
a formidable by I mean puts Zach to
shame you know what that's all I'm
trying to do today
all right dedicated to Zach Olivia's in
with a very big bite
he's already got her hand to God Hand to
God
it just tastes so bad yeah I hear people
saying it tastes really bad
oh it just stays so bad it tastes like
beef you want to wash it down with
something you can do that oh take the
glove off
[Music]
it tastes like beef jerky
Lena's back she's still
she's still shepherding us all through
this I just need something to like get
rid of this flavor yeah yeah you can
wash it down it's okay
we won't count that against you just one
to flush it down I just took it Like a
Pill by the way all of the pace good I
mean your mouth is blue so
you definitely ate it yeah it's blue my
tongue is shaking I saw that
yes so um walk us through it all right
I'll let you know
oh by the way filling up your tank to
give it a gifted thank you
sound like that Zack take note
so
it's like just like an overwhelming
sense of like pain okay that doesn't
sound good at all no that sounds
horrible how does it compare to Flamin
Hot Cheetos
it doesn't even hold a candle the
Flaming Hot Cheetos waste by Sierra I'm
in pain
ouchy
I ouch
my mouth is shaking you're doing great
I'm impressed you look you're not
sweating or anything I mean but you you
visibly you look together thank you so
much for saying that yeah
ouchy
ouchy it just like wow what a oh
I don't know how else to to tell you
like it's just so much pain the mouth
the throat is hurting your stomach not
yet not yet
oh you're free to exit anytime you know
I think I'm gonna do it yeah so here
let's just dispose of that right here
thank you so much thank you I'm sorry I
couldn't do it all but Zach very beat
you you know what all right and and you
did wait did you did she sip
did I miss it no well she just took a
small bite so she wasn't but yeah she's
sipping she's sipping all right I'm
calling it there then
I'm just giving her an answer who is
going to be at noon what the [ __ ] wait
am I the Only Hope really is either you
or Ian or yeah you or Ian okay Ian well
that's not Ian's a [ __ ] beast let's
not forget Ian yes that's true don't
count him out and you want to step up
well it's us two left and I'm going last
so I guess that I guess now
[Music]
one of them here's the competitors
[Music]
you okay Olivia
so you're stomping around while he's
doing it so can you you want to say
something to the people you're getting
ice
Olivia's getting ice it hurts after it
hurts after she'd come now Ian is one of
the fiercest competitors in H3 podcast
history he has continually
outdone everybody when it comes to fika
fish
when it comes to
anything else let's be honest eating
gross [ __ ]
yeah you take a good
take a good hit of Pep what are you
afraid of Ian but but I think we might
be having a dark horse uh here with Ian
now so Ian just hit a Pepto
he's pre-pouring
he's pre-pouring some water he told me
on the sidelines he doesn't want to do
this no none of us do
you know it's like the draft
it was my idea I sent it I pinched it
are you good with spicy food you like
spicy food no and you're hearing you
hype me up
not good
it's the truth man I'm really bad that's
my weakness is spicy food I'll eat some
nasty old fish you know garbage
at the alley like a cartoon cat like a
goat yeah but spice I'm so bad I'm
British yo your mustache is really nice
you have a good fat British mustache
right there that's Maddie no the Brits
are terrible with spice you're about to
join the queen Ian I didn't know that I
didn't know that all right well well I
personally think that
we have nuni who said lean is invited to
carne asada tonight
as you know the Mexicans love very spicy
food
up here now I I think I'm the only one
here that likes spicy food it sounds
like
I do too I love spicy food okay but I
guess I love spicy food yeah why do you
think Dan has diarrhea yeah why do you
think Dan that literally is why
well if you already have diarrhea damn
what's what point just it's not just
that my whole stomach is just it's not
good stack it up bro diary on diarrhea
you're on good company now Dan diarrhea
squared
how are you feeling after watching
everybody
honestly the one thing that I'm really
afraid of I keep sitting on my throat if
I start coughing from my throat
um I think I might choke to death like
honestly
it's scary
so I'm gonna have to be really careful
with the way I feel it
Kim how are you feeling you're the first
person to go
uh I'm feeling good now I just you know
my stomach hurts and that's about it
okay do I not get credit for what I did
no
what did you do
you dipped his toes
all right I got a brother how's your
toes feeling Zach awful my chip is all
right so so cut let's let's focus on Ian
here the legend
s you are gonna regret saying I've been
chugging the water how are you feeling
Zach
my throat feels a little [ __ ] to be
honest but I think I'll be all right
he's Zack will be all right
thank you I'm gonna be a mess when I eat
real spicy the nose is running the eyes
are going it's bad I start sweating yeah
like a pig too this is all broken up so
I guess I'm gonna have to hit the
different chunks what I recommend is
just get it all in at once you're not
going to want to go for round two I
think okay
my hand tremors are real bad right now
yeah I had lunch
Ian is ready and locked and loaded oh
God
I'm ready
all right are we good whenever you're
ready okay
oh wow Ian is all the way in
good entrance didn't touch the lips
really good entrance there
oh you can take the gloves off and just
toss them here
okay you need and you can wash it down
remember that's that's fine
there you're chilling you're doing look
like you're doing pretty good
it's down
we want you into the mic even while he
suffers a true professional
like you just
crumb a true professional I hate this
candy
how does it taste does it taste awful
like everyone says not good
does it really taste that bad a chip
what's worse the taster
ah
I don't know maybe I have the flu or
something all right so Ian is visibly
um
suffering
I'm bulging out of his head his tongue
is blue right yeah I wish you the best
Sugar Ray is rooting for you that was uh
Mark McGrath if you recall yeah yeah
great guy
sugar gay I'm not touching this one man
this is really bad no words for me and
yet other than it's really bad
you're it's all in the eyes man
you've seen some [ __ ] man
I'm really not good at this you are good
at this you're doing amazing you are
doing amazing I'm gonna hit two
literally the crying Jordan team right
now you know what that's that's more
than
that's more than you have to buddy
you're a [ __ ] King for this I
appreciate that thank you yeah you're
welcome Maria too
there he goes nine zero I understand I
recommend ice milk I think it really
helps nice and cool we also have ice
cream if you want Ian oh the ice cream's
here yes can you bring me a bottle or I
guess I could just Crush that one
because I'm next I'm scared as [ __ ]
you want to sit with me are you out of
here Ian needs to walk what happened
someone Yak Abe's yakin oh [ __ ] I forgot
about it
wait how'd they be Lino
he I just I think he's yacking I forgot
about a b dude we need to worry about a
b he's been in this the bathroom the
whole time holy [ __ ]
yeesh
all
right in you okay
you want to you want to talk to us a
little more or no
no he says
I'm telling you right now in this state
of mind there's you know all you can
feel is pain
there's your vocabulary goes out the
window holy [ __ ] there's nothing but
pain life is pain
[Music]
uh I got a note that Ian touched the mic
with the glove I don't see any residue
though oh no like the mic arm he he the
mic exactly I mean we can wipe that yeah
just so you guys know yeah thanks for
the heads up
the Mexican delegation claims Lena
as the homie
um
I want to get an update on AB before I
start because I am a little worried
about him the update is that he is
currently okay Lena in the bathroom
they're both in the bathroom
wait wait wait who Lena Ian and um I
gotta wait till the bathroom's available
my mouth still hurts a lot bro holy [ __ ]
all right this chip is out of hand do
you guys do you guys support this chip
it seems like it's yeah no my stomach is
killing me right now yeah
punch me in the gut I got a pic of Lena
on the kitchen floor
you know what guys I think I'm just
gonna not do it because Lena obviously
[ __ ] yes Zack I am kidding you Mr one
crumb bite hey which almost killed me
thank you very much
Mr one crumb over here running his mouth
on Chrome everyone knows the rules
your stomach's hurting Lena
oh no
she says her stomach really hurts you
ready is there anything else you'll need
ice milk
maybe a fresh bottle of Pepto I can just
hit do not waste that sweet milk
I just want to get my throat ready I
need to
do we have a lozenge or something that
can suck on
um
they got holes check
before you do this or yeah could I get
Zach can I get a foot rub buddy you know
what you can suck on
tell them love
love what am I sucking on
I don't know I don't want to go against
the bull smell
is another type of milk
um so I'm scared
no I do need a lawsuit okay Dan I mean
listen I do have a throat issue as
everybody knows thank you Lena a lozenge
I'm gonna do it though lozenge you mean
a lozenger
I guess I don't know if there's tomato
tomato no everybody I see in the chat
everybody saying I should go sit with
Ethan I am uh I am covering for Ian
right now I'm switching do you want me
to come sit with you hold your hand for
this well I'm gonna wait until a
bathroom's ready just yeah
it seems that a lot of people are
running to the bathroom so it's almost a
guaranteed at least little puke it's
gonna be a bad situation I'm just
starting to be able to have my mouth not
with milk or and or with ice the I don't
know how you're gonna do a show after
this bro yeah this might be the end of
the show this is the curtain I'm going
for like two hours I mean I guess it was
true I was afraid it'd be worse the fact
that you can like kind of be normal now
is pretty good okay
do it now I just want to say
yeah you can frame it up on me now I
guess or maybe
now I will say that um
I have a lot of experience with super
spicy foods
the hottest thing I ever ate was when we
did the atomic Burger the spiciest
Burger ever made on hot ones
and that [ __ ] was insane
so I've been there
but I don't know if I've eaten something
this spicy
how hot was that like what peppers were
on there uh all the same [ __ ] it's all
like scorpion [ __ ] God you know
death beelzebub's left tit
[Music]
all right
both bathrooms still occupied
this lozenge is actually helping my
throat I feel more relaxed
I got my ice milk
cheers yeah I just know that it's going
to be a rough week in the bathroom Pepto
the H3 offices well we'll have some fun
updates on Wednesday
it'll last until Wednesday you know yeah
we wrote up some cool stories Wednesday
will be good yeah for real
I had it is Wednesday one of the
spiciest things I ever ate was in Mexico
my buddy came down my parents used to
live here
and he used to love making chili
so we bought this huge
flank of meat that you slow roasted
and
they just do [ __ ] different in Mexico he
bought like five Habaneros peppers
and he put the all five of them in their
Hall
m
it's it's to this day so when the spicy
sings I hate all three of us
who ate it
the next morning we came and were
talking like we were all up at the same
time [ __ ] our brains out we're all
up all night [ __ ] lava
and then we realized afterwards but yeah
I'm sitting my pants
[Music]
all right someone have 9-1-1 on speed
dial
I got you
are both both bathrooms still occupied
here Ian's out
all right I'm gonna go to the bathroom
before I do this more stalling I'm gonna
do it
[Music]
I didn't do it
cam you're you're in the hot seat so
it's your show now take it away I love
being in the Scorpion chair everybody
Cameron grants everybody
tuning in today we have a beautiful show
lots of people are going to have
diarrhea later in the show but right now
it's beautiful I hope you out there are
having a great day night evening
wherever you may be uh you know I feel
very powerful in the Scorpion chair Dan
you are a powerful man so I think it's
so powerful I think it's mainly just
your aura that sits in this chair more
so than the Scorpions
cam I think that I should be the one
that gets to sit there today
[Music]
you're so happy
about it
but move your [ __ ] ass have you ever
sat in the Scorpion chair before Lena no
I haven't you got it you haven't lived
today hold on I'm dead I'm getting out
of here all right you're fine yeah it's
all you no it's all you do it I'm gonna
go in ABC yeah giving it up on the H3
talk show
[Music]
y'all see that cute post on Teddy fresh
today with Lena and AV oh my God it's so
dark
wow there she is
she's in the oh there we go she's the
captain now
am I muted no you're taking it away
I just wanted to say stay here that's
all okay guys this is amazing you got
your fan up here wow Dan you're really
living the life here so thank you thank
you yeah I've I've personalized it quite
a bit I love that
you good yeah all right Ian's taking
back over on the switching we're all
right leading is in charge now after
that
Amy's in the bathroom I think he's
suffering the most to be honest and and
I we knew he was he was very sensitive
so big shout out to AB
uh for what you accomplished here today
I didn't realize that there was ice
cream at my desk and I was all melty but
I'm still gonna eat it
so um all right well that's the show
guys
it's getting a little late I think yeah
we've been going for an hour 54.
um whether you like to cap the show at
two hours so you know what Ethan I have
to wrap it up just because I care about
you you do not have to do it I'll just
shut up Zach you don't have to do it you
don't have to eat like Loki the whole
thing if you're gonna be in pain and
regret it don't do it
exactly I have to lead you guys into the
battlefield Batman brand over here I
think the only thing I ever bitched out
on was the
Zoom strowman but I did end up licking
it actually the smell yeah I gave you a
horrific allergic reaction yeah so maybe
that was for the best that you bitched
down or not so what do you what do you
think are you going to be covered in
hives tomorrow no I like I said I I've
eaten really spicy food before so
look at me oh my God holy [ __ ] when you
get sick and you leave
should we end it is that it no you say
our outros or no keep it rolling I want
the whole
the whole experience I want to debrief
it all right
I might follow you with the with the
chase cam yeah roll it yeah and you're
welcome to if I'm in there yeah you know
I obviously you don't want to show
puking but
you don't have to feel bad about
following me with the camera okay you
don't have to respect my privacy so this
one's going to wear gloves
all right I just wanna no glove no love
don't forget that mm-hmm
let me hit some Pepto first
Pepto Ultra coat that throat oats and
cools cut that throat baby
oh yeah drink it down
um
does it tells you minty Ian looks Jesus
Christ
it all out so holy [ __ ]
where's your Yak blue yeah Hopper energy
though I will say thank you
that dude [ __ ] did you say he has hot
girl energy
should I wait potentially for a b like
maybe Lena can you see it maybe
God damn yeah [ __ ] we'll be waiting a
while I mean a b a b is not coming out
of the bathroom for like an hour
you know he deserves to see this he's
been through hell he probably wants to
watch me suffer
you know it's a good thing it's recorded
then yeah maybe we can go put the live
stream on a phone in the bathroom before
let's just check you know I'm not trying
I'm not I'm not trying to put it off or
anything but hmm Billy
why does it taste like that's disgusting
okay
it tastes like beef jerky I'm gonna do
one glove
I'm gonna toss it in throw it out
I don't think there's any chance I'm
gonna eat Vino though that was insane
I think even just getting it down is
pretty incredible
is Amy coming Lena
baby is not coming yeah
[ __ ] Eli are you watching this
are you out there can you call Ela and
tell her to watch please are you out
there I'll call her to know what we're
doing
I need donations from Mila
one second
oh call declined instantly oh [ __ ] ran
over my ass she's probably on do not
disturb yeah do not disturb herself
wait I'm trying again
I know you're live on the show
um Ethan wanted me to call Ethan want me
to call you and tune in if you can
because he's about to eat the the
hottest uh chip of all time
that I should come in if I can oh that'd
be great oh if you're here yeah he was
just come over in on the stream but if
if she comes over that'd be awesome yeah
I mean either way
I'm literally downstairs come on up
let's go get up here come on ela's
coming we have an extra tip we have one
extra chip all right we'll see you in a
sec all right ela's coming I bought
myself another
minute
thank you so much can you put it in the
freezer just so it
I'll forget about it and then I'll just
be like Stu thank you Lena
you seem stressed
you seem a little stressed can't help
but notice
damn we'll save once we can order
another one for you Dan
[ __ ] yeah so mine's broken already
yeah I don't know I don't know if I want
to do this after what I've just
witnessed all right so mine's broken
here's the whole thing here
I'm gonna cut it into pieces like like
we've discussed like my life it's cut in
pieces cut my life into pieces this is
my last resort
and nobody knows
suffocation no breathing don't give a
[ __ ] give us something we eat in
that's all I got
all right that's all I got I'm preparing
the bite as we wait for ELO
I'm doing the whole [ __ ] chip here I
really want to avoid touching my lips
as I've advised everyone to to avoid you
really don't want that Ellis here all
right let's go Ela come sit next to me
um just be careful do we have an extra
box if you want to do it
either you want to do it everyone did it
but like Jack and uh and uh Dan because
he has diarrhea and Sam
dude Lena [ __ ] Lina Beast modeed it
and went sick she smashed everybody so
I'm The Only Hope of to compete I was
downstairs and it
oh yeah yeah
puking
I'm like I'll go next how bad was it you
watch me and then bad
bad I'm ready I'm ready okay guys here
it is watch him do it first
you can smell it yeah see my nose is
kind of clogged I can't smell it all
right I am ready on the stopwatch
all right guys here we go
oh
it's like I'll have to do
um
it tastes so [ __ ] bad I know ready to
be jerky
there's no garlic no pepper like no no
spices on there other than just spicy
powder there's no bam
Lena can you help me just clean the
table so I don't want to touch anything
what do you feel
mine is all black and green
seem to be handling it okay so far
oh I'm about to cough so I'm just gonna
take a zip
all right we won't count that that's
just getting it down
it was water actually let me do this one
sent me here all right we're pushing the
rules a little bit no that's it okay
I was most worried about
swallowing it
but I got it down without coughing I was
caught up oh my God
holy [ __ ]
I kind of agree with you Lena then I
think we're getting it
it wasn't that bad
now it's really spicy it's so spicy
though
my eyes are getting blurry
all right oh
seems normal it's just like to hug now
it's all blue
yeah you're doing great
into the back of my throat every time I
swallow
it sounds like you puke uh yeah pretty
much everyone oh my God really
oh my God
I didn't eat the whole thing because I
didn't want them okay well
you're looking like King Charles fingers
right now
is what you didn't react like this this
is way worse
wow my throat hurts so [ __ ] bad I
don't know oh you guys are doing time
without water yes yes or or milk
let me see if I could be careful uh
you're at 220. I gotta do it
you only have uh three and a half
minutes to beat Lena no no big deal
don't even say that it's only three and
a half minutes
wait so let's see so Avery did the worst
it seems like uh yeah maybe well okay so
Olivia and Zach neither of them ate the
whole chip that's why they have a little
asterisk right there so you could pack
oh wow what's the clock is that two uh
249 250.
it's just three minutes just three
minutes to go oh my God you guys it's
the shortest three minutes of your life
it's Gonna Fly by buddy you're so [ __ ]
up so cam did three minutes and then
Lena came and smashed all the yeah Lena
was just she looks so crazy yeah it's
untouchable
show me the clock please uh it's the
three well I can okay my ears hurt
there there's the clock on the screen
keep hitting him with the Trump sound
bites
drinking milk oh you're right
three minutes
I just wanted to be Kim
all right well yeah you're comfortably
we can
uh I missed it for a second I would say
320 was your uh yeah 324.
okay I don't know how the [ __ ] he did
that man
Lena has proven to be a beast that's
what I'm saying yeah it wasn't even
close can I see myself yeah hold on let
me get this down I'm a [ __ ] Savage
you gotta do it oh my God I'm shaking
after seeing you it's my throat it's
where my throat pain is it's burning so
[ __ ] mad
when you did that one of your eyes
squinted and it was like the other was
like bulging out of it
what do you need
um
foreign
[Laughter]
am I okay no I'm not okay oh my God it
hurts so [ __ ] bad
milk Ethan is like never it's like
throat it's my throat or my my inj my
sore throat yeah oh
you might be cured after this
no
anybody got that coming okay we got it
coming oh that's ice cream ice cream
ice cream's good too slam the ice cream
oh my God
hurry hurry hurry
milk
I've never seen you like that
even when we did the spicy Burger yeah
he said before and we started this that
that was the spices yeah that one was
worse than a hot
one even then anyway
like this
thousand yards there
oh [ __ ] God
all right I have some chip residue so
I'm just being really careful
um
so Ethan how how are you a student in
high school was your GPA pretty good
I did pretty good my up until like once
I got into college
I started getting really bad grades huh
okay
so what made you guys throw up
I don't understand that I don't feel
nauseous at all no I was gagging from
the taste of the chip right away
um
[Music]
I think probably just like the
overwhelming spice I imagine
because I didn't eat the whole thing but
at one point I started burping and then
my throat started getting irritated I
thought I was gonna cough and I know I
would die if I cough yeah
yeah
like the cinema challenge if I stop
drinking milk it's just unimaginable
pain just burning
fiery
[ __ ] pain dude
how long did it take for you guys to go
away
I just am able to not have an ice cube
in the mouth my throat started closing
up and I just took a little [ __ ]
piece Leela yeah Zach like ate a corner
of the chip basically and he was stuck
at one grain of corn and then called me
a [ __ ]
but that easy to make me puke is
drinking three giant glasses of milk I'm
in pain
ouchy ikron is asking how's David
donated ten dollars said how's David
it's a good question whoa dude oh my God
so bad yes
was it fresh there's a new glass of milk
there holy [ __ ] [ __ ] balls
oh my God [ __ ] bro
so uh you up for adila what do you think
I don't think so yeah you want to just
try a little bite no just to feel what's
up
[Music]
we don't need a whole thing just like a
little corner
no
no a B's still up for the count he took
it I mean you know how bad AB is with
spicy
where is he he's in the bathroom still
yeah and he took it like a while ago
oh no no see I can't do that I gotta go
back I'm not done with work and then I
gotta head back home
who wants to see you take one little
crumb
either let's go
you're gonna do it oh I'm burping
a burping spicy burp the burps are the
worst part
the minute I get the milk out of my
mouth
[Music]
the burps also bring back the horrible
Taste of the chip like located
and it takes so long to dissolve
so dry so maybe is still uh locked up
it's evil they put it on the chip
because they know it takes a long ass
time to dissolve how did Ian do
not great not good he recovered fairly
quickly though I I do have to
acknowledge that ab and I were
joined with the bathroom wall just
sounds a vomiting coming from both of
them great bonding moment yeah
I feel like your eyes are still red yeah
not good I'm so bad with spices they're
still in my [ __ ] mouth that's the
worst part
you look like you just walked out of
seeing the notebook again
versus Pepto
[ __ ] me in the [ __ ]
[ __ ]
do it [ __ ] [ __ ] people asking
ABS live yes I just checked on him he's
alive but he is still in the bathroom
struggling so
[Music]
down that's what the chip tasted like
yeah I hate that taste it was horrible I
hate it then I don't recommend why
wouldn't they just at least try and make
it taste good I know maybe that's just
impossible with the amount I don't think
it's possible powder on there yeah it's
just coated in
now that it's been a little bit my
stomach is just like warm it just feels
very warm I don't know if you guys are
getting that too I feel like I got
punched in the gut yeah I feel like
Ethan is not gonna function today so I
gotta stay
I I wouldn't have to babysit me yeah
well the kids but all three of us all
three of the boys
that's true that's a good point I feel
bad but I don't no that's a really good
point one of us needs to be I've never
been here like that so it's not going to
be good tonight
I'm proud I think I did pretty good but
Lena may just embarrass humiliating how
much did you get even I broke three
minutes I broke your record in there
I'll take the bronzer she did six
minutes yeah she could have gone longer
too it seemed like 6 14. it wasn't so
bad eating it it's just like the
aftermath of it I had the same
experience you know
then did you do it I didn't no no I sat
out today okay I was actually already
sick from spicy food from yesterday so I
decided it was probably not a good idea
to oh my God
that one better than I feared it would
go here I was just so scared I thought
it would be worse because once it got in
my wound and my throat I think I feel
like I wouldn't be able to breathe yeah
I feel okay now
[Music]
whoa dude
all right holy [ __ ] I have to go
thank you for being here for your
support
oh my God
wait hold on we gotta get shot out hold
on don't move where have you been
you guys you guys got to do this
this man looks like he just came back
from a two-week Bender
water the floor he was just on the floor
oh my God
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ] dude
you missed man I want you to see it you
know AB promised me he wouldn't puke
today thank you I love you but I don't
blame him
promises are just words
love you thank you
thanks for dropping by Ela
I'm proud of that I think I did good
you did pretty good
you didn't throw up which is more weird
people yeah anyway
babies I
know sensitive Barbie so
very proud and and uh proud of what you
did here today yeah way to go baby
get half and half straight half this is
my third one say something I put your
number one yeah you've just been the
program that's gonna make you sick
what do you mean no you drink three
cartons I switched maybe one and a half
I am never in my life felt pain like
that my stomach felt like it was gonna
just explode that you guys want to know
I'm dirty because I was literally
rolling around like a baby crying that's
why I have pictures of Lena rolling
around on the ground oh you know that's
what I was afraid of wait Lena was
writhing on the ground just for a second
just for we had a quick that's what I
was afraid of I was looking for Elena oh
my God
the smell of puke almost set me off
walking by the bathroom earlier
wait this half and half thing is can I
get more in my mind yeah no that's I
agree insane to me that's the most
[ __ ] up thing that anybody ate today
I did almond milk too
much oh we have normal milk
oh God just a carton of almond milk and
three cartons of half and half
you want some ice cream Maybe
I hope you're lactose sure
you're not lactose intolerant I am
lactose intolerant holy [ __ ] you guys
don't know
I'm telling you sparring at fighting
everything I've ever done in my life I
split my head open when I was a kid
nothing because compared to that pain I
just went no it was insane I was like
dude please please don't let me be the
guy that's like
call the ambulance but I felt like I was
there I was afraid I was gonna be called
the Emmys because I was gonna stop
breathing
oh you did it I was literally gonna
dude I was gonna come out and say don't
do it you have kids I did it
you just missed it
I beat cam you be cam nice who who got
first oh come on Elena Lena oh good job
okay bye by a mile I thought about
trying to go for a record and I was like
there's so much pain down that line do
we is there a prize for this
yeah bragging rights
Lena got to see uh she sat in the
Scorpion chair for a while I haven't
washed my hands yet I'll be right back
that's kind of a prize yeah nice
okay
where are you going
you out oh you're just gonna wash your
hands okay
so I was trying to get them so you don't
get in the puke bathroom
so I was trying to get this ship in
Sweden they literally don't sell the
same brand it's kind of worried
no this is this is some [ __ ] [ __ ] dude
if if I ever come to America again guys
I will have one that's uh
I will
you'll try it if you come back out yeah
it's [ __ ] up somebody said a b is the
true Joker brain Zach what do you think
of that let him have it let him have it
somebody asked what is half and half
it's like uh cream right yeah it's
basically like whole cream well like
it's half and half right it's like half
milk half whole cream
it's for like cooking and stuff right
yeah people put in their coffee but like
a dab of it like not drinking a whole
[ __ ] carton of it it's like it's very
strong so I will say Zach I felt really
bad making light of your suffering after
the fact I'll never question
it's awful yeah no I felt sober I could
only imagine what Zach was going through
with that one flake of corn I got good
news or bad news boys this is gonna be
all week it was just the first impact
we're gonna be suffering all week our
stomach's gonna be mad at us
we're doing again Wednesday right yeah
exactly
[Music]
this time we're just gonna get the [ __ ]
you literally could not give me
a million dollars really a million
dollars you guys think I'm just being
dramatic I swear to God I will not take
a million dollars really because you
just did it for free I know I think the
scary the scariest part for me was my
throat like I felt it yeah yeah that
that scared the [ __ ] out of me whoa
there's puke in the sink like a lot I
saw it and I lost it who did that not me
who puked in the sink because there's
like a food catcher yeah does that mean
yeah let me describe what I just saw let
me describe what I just saw
you know those food catchers that catch
[ __ ] in the sink well yeah it caught the
puke
I saw it wait I gotta look at that dude
I got a problem wait what were you girls
stopped by dad
okay so I won't
Dan says the bathroom is horrific no I
I cleaned up after myself both of them
um
my stomach is killing me Are we almost
done
oh you okay in you you want some Pepto I
might need some more but I can't get up
who is can someone get eaten some Pepto
yeah well you can't get up because you
gotta hold your cheeks down so nothing
comes out or wait who's next to me in
the bathroom puking wait what I think it
was um that was Ian it was Ian
peeing in which bathroom was it Dan he
was he's the one I was in oh the Disco
were you on the one on the left because
that I peed in there before my turn and
it was that was immaculate it looked
fine
I literally my face is probably covered
in dirt and [ __ ] and piss and I don't
even care right now I was just rolling
around like a [ __ ] baby I literally I
sort of got in my mother's life I
contemplated putting my head in the
toilet I swear to God with the puke in
it I don't care what the [ __ ] is in it
oh man
I am Joker brain that I'm [ __ ] dude
um is the pain gone maybe
for the most part for the most part yeah
I'm proud of you dude because I knew it
was going to be real bad for you but you
did it
your eye out
and I appreciate that I'm starting my
documentaries now
Zach there's one chip left
yeah [ __ ]
all right I'm good I'm with AB you can
pay me to do that
a million bucks no no [ __ ] way I'll
take the million come on no because
nothing's scarier than panicking he
wasn't paid for 30 minutes or I don't
want to go a million dollars there's
nothing scarier than one how many
Rolexes is that not enough
brought you guys Wilding over there I
would I would yeah
a million bucks check please I need
[ __ ] 10 of them for a million nah not
worth it maybe not it's scary dude when
you think you can't breathe and you're
it's just not worth your life it's not
working
um it's not gonna kill you bro I don't
know man
go ahead
we got some Stills for me eating it
let's see
that was by far the spiciest thing I've
eaten
like
yeah
I want to see hot ones where they give
them that
just [ __ ] destroying celebrities like
literally
well this is this is worse than
the last dab or whatever oh dude the
last dab is like a [ __ ] Jolly Rancher
compared to this really
are you kidding I guess it's just one
dab instead of a whole you did the dab
didn't you no I don't think it was here
or oh you weren't there then maybe this
wasn't on camera at that time
this is
by far like I said there's this hot
pepper guy on YouTube he was suffering
bad when he ate it
and I knew we were in trouble but proud
of all you guys amazing
whoa
you got some Pepto here
ow everyone doing okay
yeah my stomach is just killing me right
now ow
how are you okay
ow
how was I was having a rough time with
you nothing
what can we take to make it feel better
Howie what do we do about it
no it's not the hot one Chips it's I
don't know who the [ __ ] what's psycho
[ __ ] she made this dude it could be
illegal it should be illegal Lucifer
what do we do about it
are you still in pain
I a little bit but it doesn't feel like
my stomach's gonna explode I think my
stomach's starting to get the yeah all
right well
moving on
let's talk about some drama
did you guys hear that um
hey do you guys want to see pictures of
us all as old people
pretty crazy
check it out
there's me
age gracefully pretty crazy huh guys
I'm amazed that you're still running the
show Dan whoa that one looks crazy good
the hell
[Music]
who's that love I don't even recognize
your old ass
I'm handsome dudes
did they give Old Dan hair
I think they took a picture of him we
still had some hair interesting Dan
he grows it out he's got some hairs
transplant or something in his older
ages
oh
oh my God is that what ELO's gonna look
like
[Music]
she looks great beautiful she does she's
glowing
hmm
this this filter is
feels scarily good
Zach it's [ __ ] awesome that dude Fox
King [ __ ] oh yeah that guy [ __ ] hard
man I'm the new Dos Equis man that looks
pretty good oh no my stomach's getting
it
dosakis those zakies yeah I'm starting
to feel maybe like cramping on my
stomach that's
that's the bad that's the really bad one
I feel like like what are you
experiencing right now yeah thanks Jake
for your concern just
the heat is going away in my mouth and
tongue
and my stomach is starting to nah what's
up Jake you haven't even done it [ __ ]
we don't care
why'd you call me you asked me how I'm
doing we don't care so so why did you
ask how I'm doing then if you don't care
just leave it alone
tested for it all right bro whatever
leave me alone stop it I'm getting
bullied by Jake Paul
oh really uh Sam
Queen
Ian
Ian queening what's going on you don't
look that different Ian
oh come on yeah I look like [ __ ] now in
the old I don't know but like a lot of
that's not exactly what I meant I just
no it's cool man I look like [ __ ]
garbage old [ __ ] I'm an old ugly ass
not my words not my words one of the
comments that you um Ian looks like Paul
McCartney in that one dude I was
thinking that that's it bro you look
like Paul McCartney Oh see that's oh
fellow Englishman [ __ ] awesome oh my
goodness gracious I can't even talk
about it Olivia what do we say about
this I'm so offended about my older self
that someone Lena told me that someone
commented that I look like I have way
too strong perfume and I'm always in a
rush yep yep
about right Howie what can we do about
this is there any way to reverse the
aging here what do we do about it
nothing nothing no there's no hope
there's no there's nothing oh at least
I'm still slaying in my Britney costume
Lena interesting
um very interesting
thoughts you're mad not mad about it
it's pretty good yeah
I'm I was I had stepped away to close
the fridge so I missed mine oh yours
look great I'll go back and show you
yours was really good oh God loves was
good too oh God I died young I'm not in
it
oh damn oh yeah oh Cam that's okay we
all got to go sometimes sometimes no
that's [ __ ] more than others killed
the car Cameron
hey Ethan I'm the Democrat Charlie
Christ running for shut up
stop
sick of telling these idiots to stop
texting me
you ever get one of those and you send
stop and they're like I'm a real person
get out
oh you know what
I did actually and you know what it was
for a Rick Caruso one and I was like
what did I say [ __ ] I responded like I
ain't voting for that [ __ ] [ __ ] or
something like that and then they were
like okay so should I take you off the
list and I was like oops but yes what do
you think
foreign
oh [ __ ]
I can't get them around funny that is
messaging stopped a real person you say
stop stop stop
they just go okay sorry okay oh all
right sorry okay so Lena's crushing
whoa dude Colonel Sanders
what do you think baby
are you conscious yeah
that's how I look right now I kind of
like you look distinguished you look
pretty good let me go back and show
Dan's
pretty good are you doing okay
my hair grew back I'm growing my hair
back together is this what you guys
imagine me to look like an old person or
I'm just you kind of just look like that
that's exactly what I look like this is
this is 40. I mean it's more it's whiter
hair now three years from now guys
would it need to be 43 no Zach I'm 37
and don't don't joke
and loves was my fave look at this guy
yo crazy that looks cool as [ __ ] it's
like yeah that looks like a nice mom
yeah but those those are some old man
eyebrows bro you look like the the uh
like real version of Mr Fredrickson from
up can you drink too much Pepto-Bismol
probably
let's find out let me look why don't
they should call it they should call it
Pepto a Bismol
thank you thank you anybody symptoms of
Pepto-Bismol overdose can include
ringing in your ears lost during an
extreme drowsiness so maybe Pepto-Bismol
overdose how much Pepto is safe all
right I'm putting this away this is the
usual dose is two tablets every half
hour to water what about bottles how
many bottles
laughs
hanging in there buddy yeah yeah
what a way to go oh deang
oh it's not this spicy that takes me out
it's the oding on Pepto you start
sieging and it's all just like pink so
if you look on the bottle and it tells
you what one dose is if you times that
by eight that's how much you're allowed
to have in 24 hours okay so it says
15 milliliter which is
half of this
not right there I'm right on the edge
man yeah
let's cut you off they're like
Pepto-Bismol overdose will result in uh
infertility loss of hearing loss of
sight cut them off it's like what the
[ __ ] life I just wanted to hear my
diarrhea
and I would rather die than do that I'm
so weird how are you Lena
I'm okay it's just my stomach
it feels like someone's like pounding it
in did you did you drink a lot of Pepto
because I think it's helping me
I love my cup here I had a lot I think
Ian's hunched over man did you drink
milk Lena
I did and I took some um Tylenol 2 right
now
any regrets does anyone wish they could
take a bath I think Ian does right yeah
absolutely [ __ ] lutely and he's like
hunched over man he just like knows the
buttons
they say you're the ghost given up Ian
they say you're the goat on the
switchboard I think this proves it
it's actually very impressive
okay maybe talk let's hope he gets you
wow
you want to you if you take the back if
you could roll back time absolutely
absolutely
I just don't even know how to describe
it guys that was I'm not an overactor I
don't Overstock it I'm dying no this
this is the this is like by far the
worst thing I've eaten
um are you mad at Zach for him getting
saying he just took a little nibble and
that it was really bad no I'm mad at my
wife madelina because she made it look
so easy dude Lena screwed all of us I
thought I'd go half that time maybe at
least
elope Lena
same amount of letters right
screwed all of us holy [ __ ] are you okay
Ian
he's been down back I was in the
bathroom and I heard Ian throwing up I
didn't know it was Ian I just like
shakily put my hand on the wall like to
reach out to well yeah
cam how you doing
I feel fine though it's just my stomach
hurts but I'm feeling fine
yeah I feel pretty much okay I'm curious
about how the [ __ ] is going to go
later that is going to be really
interesting I will say the smell of
vomit almost got me to vomit again dude
I smell like [ __ ]
yeah you look awful bro I went in there
double like dual wielding uh Febreze
Febreze bottles and just unloaded so
hopefully oh let's see if there's
anything else we can watch it's kind of
fun to just do it well
there's so much suffering I think you
might have to find a new Ian
dude he's still switching like a madman
he's not missing it can we you're not
missing a bead we've been putting off
discussing uh the two hot fantasy shows
that are out right now and maybe we can
finally do that discussion oh so I
didn't watch the new Game of Thrones oh
you did kids kept waking up last night I
can't wait to watch it but I am caught
up on Lord of the Rings
I mean it's fun so I'm enjoying it
in my opinion there's just too many
black elves but
other than that
I'm of course kidding I think it's
[ __ ] insane people are actually angry
that there's a black elf and ironically
he's probably my favorite character yeah
he's awesome so I don't see a problem he
looks like he totally looks like a cool
elf like if you want
it's like how do you care about that
like even if you're a white supremacist
right you know you know it's an elf he's
not even like a human well because it's
ruining the sanctity of of this ancient
story that's about you know 90 80 years
old
it's
based on like an index so it's not even
really Canon
urge Academy
the show well I
who determines what's Canon or not I I
guess it's not canon to the to the
specifics of the books no they've
expanded on stuff created new characters
yo got him
blood if you guys were to recommend one
or the other because I don't have time
Game of Thrones okay I'll watch Game of
Thrones in my opinion
thoughts I keep vacillating back and
forth which one I'm enjoying more
um Game of Thrones it just kind of
they're doing such different things that
it's good I feel just on another level
in terms of making
shows
like even though it's such a high budget
show and everything's beautiful it's
still kind of like got that cheesy gloss
Amazon gloss over it
I don't know what it is I I know exactly
what you're talking about I don't know
what the [ __ ] like what's up yeah it
looks it looks really cheap compared to
Game of Thrones isn't that weird because
they had like an unlimited bike I don't
agree with that at all really I mean
like you I like it more than me but like
insanely high but Lena was watching it
oh I didn't watch as much but Lena was
watching it the other night and there
was a scene where they're like in this
Tower in the background was like all
this green ring it looked so fake I
don't know it just looked like a
storybook it looks good but not not I
don't think it looks amazing I don't
know what everyone's talking about can
we do it sure well I did a poll before
the show
and uh Game of Thrones was definitely
winning although I did give a third
option neither I'm not a nerd which uh
won by a lot yeah you better take that
one between House of dragon and ring of
power I I personally I would go lord of
the or the the Game of Thrones show so
far is really good
was really good too though very I
haven't watched it yet
wow what else we got
um
Little Mermaid oh speaking of uh yeah
dude did you guys hear the little woke
trash The Little Mermaid's black and I'm
[ __ ] pissed I'm gonna [ __ ]
mermaids are white mermaid okay again
mermaids are white how do you literally
literally how are you not embarrassed to
talk to like actually have this tape
like to actually go in the public sphere
and be like I'm mad that Arielle is
black I put there's an Imgur album in
that story of all of the like horrible
things that people make it's the it's
maybe the dumbest people on the internet
oh I can't wait to look at it looking at
these Stills I actually think she looks
great I think it's super cool
interesting choice for character she
looks beautiful and her voice like we
can't play it on the show I like that
they act like the voices and part of the
equation that girl could have sang any
of the other people who auditioned under
the table like I heard one musical it's
beautiful okay wow wow that sounds great
yeah I think she looks great and this
girl has a Grammy and and many
nominations she's black right so true
and Beyonce found her but she's black so
she can't be airful I love that I see
she's so crazy he's so crazy and also
the people complaining about it like do
you they don't care about the little
mermaid no like you're not obsessed with
the little mermaid really right you know
they're really into the story it's not
your favorite movie I had this argument
when I was back home in Michigan with
some [ __ ] idiot friends of mine and
then like Midway through I'm like I
didn't know you guys were such big
little mermaids yeah exactly and then I
was like wait wait let me ask you
something what's what's the little
mermaid's name and they're like bro
that's not the point I'm like what's her
name
exactly all of a sudden if we're talking
about the Integrity of the story The
Little Mermaid Hans Christian Anderson
who wrote it literally said that like
Ariel has clear green skin and like she
literally dies at the end of his story
like that's not how Disney does it I
don't know yeah it's it's already an
adaptation of an adaptation it's like
who cares yeah and it's it's a story
about the author's
um like on inability to express the fact
that he's gay
oh oh yeah it's a motif
don't tell the mega guys that I know
they'll tell Jordan Peterson then they
can't even care about the little one
where would we be without white mermaids
so who is gay
yeah I don't know it's like you know if
let's say if you wrote a story about
yeah
George Washington and I'm not even
saying this is a bad idea because this
is what Hamilton did I thought it was
interesting
they cast like black people and Puerto
Ricans to play the founding fathers I
thought was cool
but if you're doing something where
that's not the point
and you're like oh yeah George
Washington was a black dude not that I
care like I think it's an interesting
choice regardless but these are
fictional characters
they don't have a race
like Ariel's not real you know that
right Lord of the Rings is a fictional
Place elves aren't real yeah elves are
not real yeah dwarves are not real
that said
um I don't have any problem with the
mermaid being black obviously but
I did watch this teaser trailer and what
the [ __ ] is going on with the lighting
in this what the [ __ ] that's the
lighting I can't see anything shot
it's like episode it's so dark
she's inside of her treasure trip I know
but then she like even at the end it's
just like everything seems very they're
like good it's super realistic the dog
it's at the bottom of the ocean I guess
it doesn't need to be realistic like the
problem with these live action Disney
movies they're the same thing with Lion
King we're like they didn't make the CGI
like expressive at all but it and it
just made it so awkward with everything
they were saying because I think they
directed the actors to not be expressive
it was really strange yeah I'm not gonna
watch this not because of Ariel but just
because all these [ __ ] Disney movies
oh no oh [ __ ] there's a crumb found its
way in my eye oh boy oh my God how'd
that happen oh my God [ __ ] me what do we
do what are we doing you should go rinse
it out in the sink yeah yeah I'll go
rinse it either oh she's gonna rinse it
does anyone else or something ow uh I do
have Visine actually yes
Stoner good stoner always carries Visine
man that was Karma dude this is not too
many too many Jeff whittak jokes came
back around
[Laughter]
I feel
he's watching his eye in the kitchen
sink right now
saying where did that come from
what's up cam I was just I was just
describing what's going on I'm sorry go
ahead you're doing great you have a
great narration thank you very much
frantically washing his eyeballs out in
the kitchen sink right now screaming
saying where did that come from thank
you that's all I got for now is there's
just water going in his eyes
AB did you say that you saw the um
the rings of power you've watched it I
watched some of the first episode but I
fell asleep because it was late only the
first episode yeah not because it was
bad yeah
with you though Don I kind of I'm split
between both both I'm almost leaning
more to to the Rings you're leaning more
towards the Rings huh I think so I like
the story more what did you think of the
character the Mind Goblin
the Mind Goblin mind Goblin these nuts
oh [ __ ]
sorry I applaud you for that that was a
good one I did not see that coming that
was really good F-18 bro I can't say
that I came up with that there was some
Reddit post where somebody uh
somebody set it up with the Mind Goblin
thing oh with with uh the Rings same
dude look at all is it I literally just
stole that from Reddit I can't take
credit for it look at all the
contrarians in our audience which do you
like more house or dragons ring of power
I like both equally both are bad
both are bad both are batters winning
really it's like come on you guys don't
feel like wait wait how's your eye you
think seriously it's so it's fine it
must have been a really tiny little
flake okay
um while you were away love said that
he's leaning towards he likes both shows
but he's leaning towards uh the Lord of
the Rings show cool
yeah
I feel like I feel like whichever one I
saw most recently is the one that I'm
like I think I like that yeah
in you okay
no
do you need anything
get down bad man go to bed oh [ __ ] you
want you you want us to end the show
uh or maybe someone could take over for
you either we in the show or the show
ends meet let's we can wrap it up we've
been going two hours 45 minutes well I
was gonna say about Arielle you know
it's like okay if you're worried that
she's black then be worried that there's
light at all because there's no light
deep in the ocean so it should just be
pitch black if we're really looking for
realism here
forget about Arielle the whole movie's
block are any of these Disney Live
Action remakes any good at all like I've
never did I could get the Goosebumps
when I watched this trailer I'll be
honest you were into it huh dude the
Aladdin remake was so [ __ ] stupid oh
my God
stupid
into this great we started on The Lion
King oh yeah I was gonna say that I
didn't even watch it it was it horrible
it's so bad
it's so bad and like it's crazy because
they had the same actor Cassis Mufasa
but his dialogue is so much worse than
this one I think because like I said
they wanted them to not be expressive
with their voice to match the CGI
you know
I think the only one that was halfway
decently reviewed was The Jungle Book
there was the first one they did was it
not I think that was what started this
whole Trend but it was only one real kid
and the rest was CGI so it's not even
the same
oh [ __ ] all right well let me just
browse through here real fast
um oh I wanted to look at hate comments
okay Ian let me just look at a comments
since we're on the topic already
let's see I already opened it
let's see so Disney will be firing this
woman come May 2023 she no longer
matches your art who said that
great now every white woman in the world
has been fired because of you
are you gonna give her someone else the
job now huh
well also
sorry uh one person
you're worried about one person damn
devastating to the job market
also the original cartoon isn't going
away literally oh of course why can't
everybody be Ariel like I don't stupid
yeah like well are you gonna go tell a
little black girl Joseph is Ariel on
Halloween uh you need to take that off
you're the wrong race sweetie you need
to take that off you're limited to
these black Princesses only
I'll let you get away with the uh
with the Samoan one but that's it
race swapping
is not okay
just because it's a white character for
a change
AKA every single time not my REO
stop race swapping
bro Lord Bern friendo you've never seen
this movie you literally are just a
[ __ ] freak
ew what the [ __ ] she's ugly and has the
wrong skin color who are you literally
hashtag not my Ariel
horrible not my Ariel yeah that was a
literal that tweet has been trending
three separate times since 2019 when
they announced that she was humiliating
to actually tweet and hashtag not my
aerial literally I was thinking about
blurring the users and I was like No let
people see yeah yeah
this is not my Ariel okay Jack you
[ __ ] weirdo
that's I don't think I don't want you
having an aerial okay Jack Twitter is a
rock too old okay you just [ __ ] mind
hey he's a film junkie all right
it is funny how dark this is the only
frame they could got is so [ __ ] dark
but this is what's so annoying this
keeps happening with these Disney movies
is like
something like this like you know they
cast uh they cast a black woman is Ariel
or or or whatever it is that people are
upset up for this one and then it
becomes like
a battlefield in the culture War
[ __ ]
but then you feel like you can't
criticize it because then you don't want
to be on the side of these weirdo racist
people but like
I'm sorry I know that you did enjoy
Olivia but to me that trailer looked
like [ __ ] but not because she's black I
don't care about that whatsoever just
don't say not my real right just not
your Little Mermaid movie yeah yeah yeah
you're good
not my REO Disney Studios any reason why
everything has to be black
everything
are you starting to realize people are
fed up and frankly bored
you do realize this is going the
opposite with racism yeah but you that
Hercules actor and Meg will be black go
woke go broke
Disney is one of the most profitable
companies that ever exist
and these people will always argue that
oh I don't care if they make a new
mermaid a new black mermaid but I just
don't want Ariel Ariel's not the
original they'll say the same thing
about like Clark Kent but if you ever
want to expose a racism just ask them
about 007 like okay what about double
seven yeah I would love Adria Elvis yeah
because but double seven is not supposed
to be the same person one person you
know yeah it was the same dialogue and
and that was one of my favorites because
it's like what is the first thing you
think about when you think James Bond
he's a British spy
that's it since when you know what I'm
saying like such a self-report yeah
British spy
you know it's like saying oh well uh
what was the new guy's name
Daniel Craig Daniel Craig doesn't look
anything like Pierce Brosnan right he's
a different guy
it's the same thing
[ __ ] pathetic freaks dude
God Lee G willikers
yeah they go everything there's like
four characters in like the whole
anthology of Disney
same energy
okay racist freak and what the [ __ ] this
is it's from uh Harry Potter
there's being [ __ ] different worlds
yeah that's like an evil mermaid from
Harry Potter
okay oh my God this donation from Molly
mind this Ariel black better not be
italic
because that's the name of a font that's
pretty clever Molly pretty clever you
got jokes Molly thank you for that I'm
gonna have to revisit that one there
Molly
can you read that again for me Dan here
it'll
be Arielle black better not be italic
Arielle black is a font right okay okay
but also yeah you get it I'm there I'm
right there with you girl mm-hmm
yes ma'am
yes ma'am did fifth
it's been free
hit me with that Zach where's Baron lady
you looked at me
one more time it's been fit daddy look
at me
shut up when it says he said he said I'm
sorry wait one more it's been
so stupid
yeah so anyway we support
hello hello yeah like like if you say
what is the characteristics of Arielle
the Merm the the let's say the lady and
the Little Mermaid what do you think
about when you think of Arielle
red hair Hot Fish lady
mermaid red hair if we're talking clear
physicals red hair is the most and like
and she's a [ __ ] mermaid yep nobody's
gonna say white no I was like well she's
she's white she's got red hair she's so
stupid her family Origins go back to
England yeah
foreign they colonized the West
genocided and Native Americans
and then became mermaids
then [ __ ] a dude interspecies sex
ually like [ __ ] a dog
Arielle now if you want to criticize
Arielle let's talk about bestiality for
a minute someone got PMP on the line for
example when I jerk off Donnie
oh God this episode just turned into a
fever dream now what do we got here
again Donnie a young black girl sees
black Arielle yeah this is
this is their worst nightmare let's
let's play this with horror music uh
Zach
this is how these people see this video
Mermaid trailer
[Music]
look
spooky
got any Lightning Crashes or something
[Music]
[Music]
yeah it's not really working to match up
they're about to see her face
so creepy huh this is so [ __ ] up this
is America's nightmare wow this is
civilization not you too Disney these
delightful little girls enjoying
themselves that was so nice
[Music]
like yeah you could you could kill it
thanks
um
all right I think that's about it we'll
let Ian out of here know
where is the inch put message let me see
you again he's down he hasn't lifted his
head this whole time nope that's so
interesting
all right guys well we did it I mean
[Music]
before we sign off let's just check in
on everyone cam how you feeling
you're good good back to normal fine I
mean I'm just
the bathroom's gonna be rough for this
week but whatever Lena
me too I'm hanging in there hanging in
you feeling pretty much back to normal
oh
[Applause]
are you surprised that you handled that
so well I am
just a bit though because that stomach
pain that came after that was a little
unbearable
I still can't believe what you did that
was insane dude well thank you Dan how
are you feeling me I feel great okay
good yeah normal
uh Ian how you feeling back there buddy
yeah
cool good as ever yeah okay just keep it
on yourself there you for a minute
all right thanks buddy a b
itch going great
like a new man how do you feel is your
stomach [ __ ] up what's going on with
you yeah it's it's it's bearable though
you feel it you know you're feeling a
little better why are you re-watching
the moment maybe he's literally watching
himself eat the chip right now what are
you just like reliving the trauma it
honestly was just playing it's just
going straight to look at it but it's
rewind time you know I've never had pain
like that where there's no lapse in the
pain like it was contagious for like
10 minutes at least I don't know
but yeah good times great another
amazing I feel pretty much better now
yeah yeah that's good yeah at least that
you know what I mean that's the nice
thing about spicy is you know
that not too long from now you'll feel
you'll feel better you know
you know what I'm saying here we have a
before and after of a b
ah
that's [ __ ] awesome
yeah
that's Monday versus Friday I guess it's
just something about anything for the
show baby
I know it man
that's not a knock exacto Zach was right
all along and I'm sorry buddy I didn't
believe you
it's all good baby
uh Olivia
do you feel totally fine
yeah you did pretty good too okay and
then of course fine young Zack who uh
among against all the odds he dipped his
toes he dipped them he dipped the toes
maybe he had one kernel of corn and
[ __ ] up my stomach I'll tell you that
much and he of course is suffering
immensely so everybody send your prayers
to Zach who ate one kernel of corn
Melania is deadly
but it's more than Dan and Sammy
the whole spectrum of reactions here
today I'm proud of you guys man all of
you even Zach you what came out here you
tried it you were the first one so that
is good all you man I'm I'm amazed we
all survived this one
wow how's your throat pain my throat and
mouth totally fine my stomach is they're
gonna take a nice juicer tonight oh my
God juicer I don't know how to describe
it I don't know because I had three
glasses of milk and I ate a bunch of ice
cream so I don't know if it's I don't
know what it is
that spicy cow tonight my guy spicy
pesto whatever it is it ain't right yeah
but Dave's gonna be your best friend
yeah and we get some prep age too oh I
wanted to read some of the one chip
reviews Dan because I didn't want to I
didn't want to do it before I wanted to
read a mask these people are suffering
let let my people go just read me one
all right so you're Moses and I'm
Pharaoh yeah
exactly you didn't even need a chip
gonna start raining frogs up in here
Ian's had his head down for the last 30
years mad man dude I know but I'm trying
to trying to help a brother out here
let's just get one right I'm reading the
reviews here we go
um
just read the first review
in 18 Years of Living buying this was my
biggest mistake to date so I ordered two
of these for my brother and I to do and
I'll start with the fact that I have
never eaten a chip that tastes so gross
in my life it was legitimately
disgusting and of course three seconds
after you start chewing on it you're
stuck with uh an awful stinging feeling
in the mouth of possibly a few tears and
all the while absolute struggle to
swallow this monstrosity I went about
three minutes without eating or drinking
anything and then I went for the
chocolate milk ice cream uh which helped
only a little while it was in my mouth
with no lasting relief then about maybe
eight minutes I started to move to my
stomach I only describe the feeling as
one million bees sting oh my God the
entirety of my mouth and throat and ears
for some reason same feeling in the
stomach the only thing that saved me
from the heat would probably be the fact
that it made me vomit all my dinner
which still left the burning feeling for
a while after laying down in the shower
for half an hour and then eating some
chips to settle my stomach I feel fine
all I'll say is that you've never done
any sort of spice challenge before this
please don't do this waste of money and
wasted the dinner I 8 but if you want a
chip that's going to make you wish you
went back in time and never even thought
of ordering it then get this chip that
is literally the top review on Amazon
and I love and shout out to everyone who
reads that and goes yup
what's the reviews on that chip like out
of five on Amazon star ratings it's
um I mean it has four and a half out of
five four and a half out of five people
love it what doesn't have four and a
half out of five on animal hold on what
did that guy rated out of five stars he
rated it
[Music]
[Applause]
did you get a little heat on that sneeze
no I've never eaten you you do it you
hate it you love it beware seriously I'm
just reading the headlines of all the
other reviews on here eat at your own
risk
yeah way overpriced dude they were
expecting a bag of chips they didn't
realize what they were ordering no but
it is these people are cleaning up it's
a 10 bucks for one [ __ ] chip yeah
that's pretty good that's a good
business right there
all right
anything else
love you still gonna eat that once it
gets to you
um well I when when you were at the
bathroom I said um they did they don't
sell it here
oh we can share we can ship you one
yeah I I said I was going to do it when
I come to America at some point uh but
okay yeah that'd be good we could wait
for that yeah
oh God
uh people are pointing out that you just
sneezed into your hat and then put it
back onto your head yeah I'm trying to
protect them not me
it's already inside me what what is it
gonna do get more inside me
I suppose so is that the secret to a
good hairline just put boogers there's
no boogers there's no snot I promise you
there's a lot more sanitary than [ __ ] I
did today
my mouth was legit on the floor like
that holy [ __ ] why on the floor
you know what I'm glad I'm just happy to
say we did that I mean we did that I
can't imagine anything spicier than that
I think we did it
we did it cool yeah I thought it was
gonna be a lot worse than it was it was
bad that's interesting because I I don't
know how much worse it could have been I
I think I've had something way worse
before in the past what what did you eat
that was worse it was called the end
sauce and uh it was yeah it was way
worse
really yeah this is the end
my only friend
I think what's so evil about that chip
is just how long it forces you to keep
it in your mouth before you swallow it
because like sauce you can kind of just
wash down and also because it's a
tortilla chip it's like gets stuck in
your teeth and in your gums and like
well after I had eaten it it was still
picking bits out of my teeth dude
all right foreign
I'll talk about that on Wednesday
right Ian
all right say goodbye Ian and then we'll
we'll log off
dude he's out
what a guy all right everybody that was
a hell of an episode huh yes sir fun
time Good times yes sir good time wild
times memorable times wow
you know that's what it's all about
we've definitely got to get Lino prize
we got to think of something she
deserves something incredible for that
that was a that was a tour de force
do you have any requests Lena
you want a Rolex it wasn't that bad Lena
Lena I don't need a prize or anything it
wasn't it was easy girl stop saying that
you're making us all look bad Lena wants
a Jeep too so yeah if you want to get
her a Jeep Ethan a Jeep
[ __ ]
oh anyone else want to enjoy the
Scorpion chair Lena you can have it
permanently that was nice too okay
that'd be kind of funny if Lena was in
the Scorpion chair I'm not gonna lie if
that was her new chair it was just more
fun to Dethrone cam that's all yeah I
mean you earned it though I didn't I
didn't mind at all dethroned them you
[ __ ] murdered him
well no cam was sitting in the Scorpion
chair and oh she she like get the [ __ ]
out of here
all right we'll think of something good
but anyway uh thank you guys what a fun
time yada yada yada God bless you guys
on Wednesday
[Music]
we'll see we'll see on Wednesday how we
made it through this couple next couple
days so you know see you in hell guys
[Music]
foreign
[Music]